ein
und
kasselend
busy früher heut
kekona
10 Minuten früher als sonst
kirkona
gucken ob
teams nicht wieder mal ein mikrofon umgestellt hat
hat es, exellent
so ein scheißprogramm
typen
dancegame
kasselend
so ein scheißprogramm
so ein scheißgramm
kasselend
Ja, dann legen wir mal los, so 100% nicht wach bin ich ja nicht.
Tja, mittlerweile so viele Emotes hier in meinem Board, ich finde gar nicht mehr die ganzen
Emotes, wenn ich sie brauche. Guck mal, ich habe da so viel Zeug mittlerweile drinne,
ich finde das gar nicht mehr. Einzige, was ich finde, das ist das Allerwichtigste, das
finde ich, aber ansonsten, ich habe hier bis heute noch nicht implementiert, dass man die
Emotes nicht mehr aufsteigen und droppen kann, dann würde ich es vielleicht auch besser,
besser finden. Trinkst du morgen was Koffeinhaltiges? Nee. Habt ihr die Geschichte mit Wendler mitgekriegt?
Ich weiß, das ist schon wieder old news, das ist schon wieder out day, das ist schon wieder
drei Tage her, aber ich finde ja meine Emotes gar nicht mehr. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel einer
sagt, mach Pepe, oder Pepe Hens, da. Boomer, da. Das ist schwierig, ich finde die meisten
Sachen nicht. Sobald ich es jetzt hier im Fullscreen habe, bei dem anderen habe ich
es nur verteilt über den Monitor, dass das es noch mal anders angeordnet. Hey Max, du
hast dir ja schon FreeNAS und X, ich mache mal den Chat auf, dass man Sachen nachgucken
kann. Jetzt immer vergesst, dass ich eigentlich Darkseam an habe. Also, hey Max, du hast dir
ja schon FreeNAS und Xpnology angeschaut, könntest du ja mal ein Stream mit Unraid machen,
das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, damit hatte ich bisher noch nie großartig was zu
tun. Ich meine, ich kenne das. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich kenne das, aber ich war bisher
von der Idee nicht so begeistert. Aber wir können uns das mal im Stream angucken. Das
ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. What the fuck? Warum? Ja, wenn er meint.
Ja, aber das mit Unraid können wir uns wirklich mal angucken. Das ist keine schlechte Idee.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das zuletzt vor keinem drei Jahren oder so. Moment. Hat der gerade
Unraid Max FPS vorgeschlagen im Titel? Habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen? Warum? Ich
habe mit Unraid überhaupt nichts. Hä? Warum hat er mich eben im Titel vorgeschlagen?
Das verstehe ich nicht. Das ist meine Hand, das erkenne ich. Das ist meine Hand und mein
Teppich. Ich wollte fragen, ob du Max FPS bist. Ich bin Wubblors natürlich. Nee, aber da stand
eben echt in der Titel, weil ich Unraid eingegeben habe, stand da Max FPS dabei. Ich habe doch
nie was zu an... Ja, da habe ich irgendwas getweetet. Ach stimmt, den habe ich übrigens
immer noch rumliegen. Den habe ich immer noch rumliegen, den 10G Switch. Tja. Das habe
ich nicht gemacht. Video machen. Video machen, Alter. Ja, warum? Ja, aber das können wir
uns wirklich mal anschauen in einem der nächsten Streams. Ist das mittlerweile so, dass man
das... Hatte das nicht irgendeine Abo-Gebühr oder so am Anfang? Oder bringe ich das jetzt
irgendwie mit Plex oder so durcheinander? Pricing. Das kostet was. Up to 6th storage
devices. Zählt da auch ein USB Stick dabei. Okay, man kann es mit Trial ausprobieren und
wahrscheinlich kann man das easy... Auf was basiert denn das? Ist das irgendein Debian
oder was ist da unten drunter? Ist das irgendein Debian oder so drunter? Oder was haben die
da unten drunter? Bestimmt Slackware oder irgendwie so ganz abgedrehtes Zeug. Das ist
garantiert nicht hier from scratch, das ist bestimmt irgendwas, das irgendwo aufsetzt
drauf. Und die Frage ist, hat man Zugriff auf das System unten drunter? Keine Ahnung.
Müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Okay, okay, okay, das ist gar kein Abo. Ich dachte erst,
das ist ein Abo. Das kostet 59 Dollar ein Mal. Ja, okay, das geht ja. Das geht ja. Ja,
können wir uns... Ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben, das gucken wir uns an. Vielleicht gucken
wir uns sogar im Mittag schon an, mal gucken. Ich habe es ja irgendwo hier aufgeschrieben.
Übrigens hier, ich habe mir jetzt mal eins davon bestellt, das was wir letztens bei Aliexpress
gefunden haben, dieses Thermostat. Das kommt aber glaube ich erst am Dienstag oder so.
Da ist ein OpenBSD drunter. Nee, das kann nicht sein. Du kannst auf Unraid KVM und Docker
und Gedönslauf lassen. Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es das nicht auch irgendwie als BSD Geschichten
gibt, aber das wäre sehr merkwürdig. Nee, nee. Aber Underlying OS. Gucken wir mal.
Ja. Slackware. Ich habe es gerade noch als Witz gesagt. Ich habe es gerade noch als Witz
gesagt. Es ist bestimmt Slackware oder sowas abgedrehtes und jetzt ist es ernsthaft Slackware?
Das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein. Alter, Slackware. Ist das euer Ernst oder? Was ist
so ein fucking Slackware? Was ist denn da los? Ich habe es nicht gedacht, dass irgendeiner
Slackware verwendet. Wir haben auf der Arbeit einen, der ist ganz abgedreht. Der hat auch
so ein uraltes Linux, wobei war es vielleicht Slackware, aber Linux History Tree. Da gab
es so einen Baum, der hat so ein ganz alles, genau, der hat so ein richtig oldschool uraltes
Linux gehabt. Könnte sogar Slackware. Alter, guckt euch das WTF. Wie soll man da hier was
erkennen? Okay, alles klar. Dann hat er Slackware. Der hat sowas richtig abgedrehtes und ich habe
euch ja erzählt, dass sie bei uns auf der Arbeit gerade ein bisschen durchdrehen, was
Windows angeht, weil wir hatten jetzt so einen Verschlüsselungsdreher und jetzt hatten sie
ja die glorreiche Idee, die haben sich so Support eingekauft von Microsoft und jetzt
hatten sie ja die glorreiche Idee, man kann Linux Systeme durch Windows ersetzen, was
das Ganze natürlich viel sicherer macht, wenn man schon mal einen Verschlüsselungsdreher
hat, der nur Windows angegriffen hat, ist ja logisch. So und jetzt sind sie auf die glorreiche
Idee gekommen, man soll auf allen Linux Systemen zu Analysezwecken den Windows Defender installieren.
Jetzt wollen sie Windows Defender auf allen Linux Dingern installieren. Wohlgemerkt, wir
hatten ein Problem mit Windows-only-Kisten und Windows-only-Viren. Wie man jetzt darauf
kommt, irgendwelche Linux-Dinger zu ersetzen, entzieht sich mir vollkommen meinem Verständnis,
ich schweige die Logik dahinter, verstehe ich auch nicht, aber so ist das halt, so ist
das halt im Business-Enterprise-Stonks-Umfeld, da muss man sowas, da muss man sowas nicht
verstehen. Achso ja, auf Linux Notebooks Klein soll das auch installiert sein und ein Kollege
von mir hat sich das installiert und ist erstmal das Notebook gefriest und konnte immer starten.
Geiles Zeug. Was soll ich mir angucken, Aliexpress. Leute, ich mache jetzt mal den Aliexpress-Link
vom Chat auf, ihr wisst, ich mache sonst selten ungesehene Links auf, aber mal gucken. What
the fuck. Das ist was für ein Sebaro. Adorino Uno Weep Edition. Ich mein, Gott, ähm, ich
mein, Gott, ähm, Versand nach Deutschland. Das Geile ist ja, dass der Versand bei Aliexpress
so billig ist, dass der, also meistens, dass, also ein Versand von Deutschland nach Deutschland
ist billiger als, äh, ist teurer als ein Versand von China nach Deutschland. Okay,
ein Raspberry Pi kaufen lohnt sich nicht. Es wird mal Zeit, dass die, dass die, was, genießen,
genießen Ausgaben Zeit mit ihrer Kinder zu Hause auch verbe... Was? Ähm, warte mal,
was wollte ich jetzt sagen, dass, ja ja, wie gesagt, Versand. Ja, es wird mal Zeit, es
wird mal, genau, jetzt weiß ich, was ich sagen will. Es wird mal Zeit, dass die Chinesen
den Raspberry Pi nachbauen, weil dann kriegst du einen Raspberry Pi Aliexpress Edition,
kriegste dann wahrscheinlich für 20 Dollar oder so. Wobei, es gibt ja schon so, es gibt
ja schon so, ähm, Raspberry Pi Nachbauten. Die kranken aber alle halt da dran, dass es
kein 1 zu 1 Raspberry Pi Fake ist, sondern irgendwelche Sachen anders machen, was dazu
führt, dass Raspbian und das ganze Zeug nicht funktioniert. Und das Wichtigste am Raspberry
Pi ist der ganze Community Support drum herum. Ansonsten ist der Raspberry Pi jetzt nicht
so der absolute Wahnsinn. Das Gute am Raspberry Pi ist, der ist billig, okay, war billig bis
zum Vierer, ähm, der hat genug Power für die meisten Sachen und es gibt halt massig
Community Zeug an Software, an Tutorials, an allem möglichen Kram und das ist eigentlich
das, was den Raspberry Pi gut macht. Wo wir gerade beim Thema Raspberry Pi sind, ich hab
in irgendeinem Video Top Raspberry Pi Projekte, das gucken wir uns gleich mal an und ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher, dass davon nicht ein Projekt dabei ist, was mir gefällt. So, gucken
wir mal, ob es da noch irgendwelche Sachen gibt. Da ist die Moab. Oh, gibt es, gibt es
nen, gibt es wieder ne, ne alternative Dings, äh, wie, wie, wie, was heißt das nochmal?
Oh, nee, nee, das, früher war das alter IW-Net, ich hab aber keine Ahnung, wie es jetzt heißt,
äh, diese nach, nachgebaute Servergeschichte für die alten Call of Duty-Teile, gibt's
anscheinend wieder was Neues. So, was gucken wir, zeig mal her, was kriegen wir hier empfohlen?
So, was gucken wir, zeig mal her, Moab, Super Pi, boah, das ist, äh, das ist in Oracle,
warum kriegen wir Videos von Oracle empfohlen? Ihh, darf man Links rein schicken, ja, solang's
keine, äh, Monka Toss-Links sind schon, aber ich hab eh so ein Vorschraub-Plugin, wenn
ich die Maus drüber mach, seh ich, was es ist, bevor ich's aufmache. Warum kriegen wir
Oracle Sachen empfohlen? Java, es wird ja immer schlimmer, es ist nicht nur Oracle,
es ist auch noch, wollen die ernsthaften Raspberry-Pars auf Java be- ach du große Scheiße. Was ist
das? Ist das ein Gürteltier, oder was ist das? Äh, habt ihr, habt ihr auch das Problem,
dass YouTube seit ein paar Tagen den, den, den Pausobutton verbackt? Guck mal, der Pausobutton
spackt rum. Das ist erst seit zwei, drei Tagen so. Und auch nicht immer, ich hab noch nicht
so genau gecheckt, wann. Als was Arbeit ist zu, äh, mach mal Ausrufezeichen, was ist es,
Ausrufezeichen Arbeit, Ausrufezeichen Job, Ausrufezeichen, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr,
eins davon ist es, und da gibt's eine Erklärung, was ich mache, wo ich mal versucht hab, das,
äh, innerhalb von ein, eineinhalb Minuten ordentlich zu erklären. Und der Sebaro hat
sogar einen Text dazu geschrieben. Cute-Mod in Aktion. Oh, wie er sich rumrollt. Gürteltier.
Schlamm, Schlamm, Schlamm. Okay, das ist, es ist nur gut, wenn überall Schlamm dran ist anscheinend.
Das ist das Gegenteil, das ist das Gegenteil von, äh, dem, was die Katz macht. Die machen
sich sauber oder macht sich dreckig. Okay, ich, ich guck mal kurz hier drüber, ob, building
a superpie. He doesn't, he lacks critical information.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem YouTube-Player hier unten los? Habt ihr das auch? Das ist voll
ner, also, ja. Hatte, hatte, hatte irgendjemand drauf geantwortet im Chat? Nee, habt ihr
nicht? Okay, verstehe nicht. Warum? Warum hab nur ich das wieder? Okay, Oracle, zeigt
mal, was ihr könnt. Das ist ein bisschen stabil für Raspberry Pi. Okay, ein fertiges
Dreck nehmen war nicht, war nicht diskutabel oder was? Das geht nicht. Ja. Oh, guck mal
hier ein. Ja, wahrscheinlich wird es ein Raspberry Pi Cluster, aber ich bin mal gespannt, ob
die auch zeigen, was sie dann damit machen, weil die meisten Raspberry Pi Cluster Sachen,
die ich bisher gesehen hab, waren halt hochgradig sinnlos. Also, das Video ist leise, ich weiß,
ich will den auch gar nicht labern hören, ich will mir eigentlich nur angucken, was
die machen. Weil die Musik ist zu laut, das Gelaber ist zu leise, die Musik ist zu laut.
Die können das nicht, die können das nicht richtig abmeschen, das hatten wir schon mal.
Das ging, das ging das nicht gebacken. Also, Raspberry Pi Cluster sind total sinnlos.
Das einzige, also, okay, 100% nicht sinnlos, kann man immer nicht sagen, aber die einzige
Sache, die mir einfällt, wozu ein Raspberry Pi Cluster sinnvoll wäre, ist vielleicht
zum Lernen von irgendwelchem Cluster Zeug. Aber sinnvoll, was man da drauf betreiben
kann, fällt mir jetzt ernsthaft nix ein. Oh, guck mal, zwei Grills. Drei. Oh, das ist ja
bei richtig, das ist ja mal ein ordentliches Verhältnis bei Oracle, weil normalerweise
bei uns haben wir, also, ich überleg grad, haben wir überhaupt Mädels? Ja, wir haben,
wir haben, bei den Datenbanken haben wir eine und wo wir, wo wir auf der Arbeit relativ
viel Mädels haben, ist eben bei iOS App Entwicklung haben wir relativ viele, aber das ist so Apple-Zeug,
so Apple-Zeug ist bei Mädels eh beliebt und was quasi, was quasi komplett aus Mädels
besteht, bei uns ist die Personalabteilung. Ach, das ist ein richtiger Raspberry, das
ist kein Zero Cluster, das ist so ein richtiger Raspberry Pi Cluster, okay. Also mit den normalen,
mit den Zeros. Okay, sie haben sich irgendwelche Sachen 3D gedruckt, sieht zumindest ein bisschen
so aus. Ich mein, es ist schon irgendwo eine coole Geschichte, aber es ist halt, es ist
halt vollkommen sinnlos irgendwie. Nicht, dass es was schlechtes ist, wenn man sinnlose
Sachen macht. Wie viele Stück das sind, gute Frage. 1000 oder so, also das ganze Rack,
schwer zu sagen, ich mein 1, 2, 3, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, okay, keine Ahnung,
sagen wir mal 40 hier rum und dann ist das ganze irgendwie mal 10. Moment, da sind, da
wären ja schon 400 auf einer Höhe, keine Ahnung, dann sind es, sind es dann 4000? Es
sind viele auf jeden Fall. Das geht ja das ganze Rack hoch. Guck mal, hier sieht man
es, hier sieht, nee wobei, nee, nee, nee, das ist nur eine Sache. Nach hinten kommen
ja auch noch welche, die gehe ich mal von aus. An die hinten kommt ein Switch rein,
okay, aber an die Seite kommt auch noch, oder nur vorne, nur vorne, dann kann man es zählen,
nee hinten auch noch, nee dann kann man es zählen, bin ich jetzt zu Lowbring das zu zählen.
Da wollten sie lustig sein. Einmal erstmal, erstmal einen Billing Netgear Switch, ja gut
warum nicht, der tut es ja. So und, okay das ist der 3D Drucker für die Gehäuse, was
machen wir, was machen sie jetzt damit? Zeigen sie auch noch was, was wir damit machen. Network
Booting Oracle Linux and Running Java, genau, das ist auch das erste was mir so in den
Sinn kommen würde, wenn ich 4000 Raspberry Pis habe. Oracle Linux und Java laufen lassen,
exakt. Ja die zeigen aber gar nichts damit, das ist ja doof. Ich meine, die hätten jetzt
im Prinzip einfach nur die Dinger ins Rack stecken können und sie einschalten. Man sieht
ja überhaupt nicht, dass sie was machen. Ja verstehe ich nicht. Man hätte ja zumindest
mal zeigen können, dass sie damit irgendwelche Sachen noch nicht mal schnell berechnen für
so viele Kisten, halt berechnen. So, was haben wir da noch, warum Computer an Schach, machen
sie? Ich dachte Computer spielen besser Schach als die besten Menschen aktuell. What it was
to buy Computer in 1994, ok, excellent, zeig her. Das ist so ein typischer Kokona Shop,
alle mit diesem Holzfällerhemd und der Kappe auf, das sieht so extrem krass Kokona aus,
ich weiß, ich kanns nicht beschreiben, aber es sieht einfach hardcore Kokona aus. Moment,
warum, das war schon 1994 Schwachsinn, warum brauche ich einen, naja. Moment, Apple hatte
ernsthaft Laserdrucker? Ok, wusste sie nicht. 1900 Dollar, da lachste dich heute kaputt
für einen ordentlichen PC. Excellent, guck mal hier. Jetzt hat er die Auswahl zwischen
dem Apple und, Moment, warum ist da, warum rauscht das? Monitore haben damals auch noch
nicht gerauscht. Warum rauscht das denn? Oder ist das die Kamera, die das aufnimmt?
Also ich kenne kein, selbst CRT-Monitore habe ich nie gesehen die gerauscht haben. Fernseher
haben gerauscht, weil das Signal halt, weil da kein Signal da war und die random Zeug,
was so da ist. Ich habe gehört, ich habe mal in irgendeinem Video gehört, dass, wenn
man sich dieses Rauschen vom, ich muss das mal zeigen, weil die meisten von euch kennen
das wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr, wie das aussieht. So sieht das aus, ja. Und so hört
sich das an, wobei das ist schlecht kompressionsartifaktet. Also sowas wie das halt, sah das halt im
Fernseher aus, wenn du nichts angeschlossen hast. Und ich habe ein Video gesehen, da hat
einer erzählt, dass in diesem random Signal zwei Prozent kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung
sind. Exzellent, das hat man natürlich sofort erkannt. Was? 68? Oh, was? 68? 86? Was soll
denn das sein? Das ist aber ganz schön alt, für 1994. Apple-Geduldensalaat. Das ist,
das ist so krass Kokona. Dieser ganze Shop und die Leute sind so hart Kokona. Exakt wie
ich mir vorstelle, ey. Oh, huge Videoplayer. Oh, ist das ein Fax? Leute, ich überlege
gerade, was das ist. Es ist kein, es ist wahrscheinlich kein Fax und es wird wahrscheinlich auch keine
Schreibmaschine sein, hat so viel die Tastatur. Ist das, was ist das? Eine Tele, ne, ich habe
keine Ahnung, was ist das? What the fuck? What? Ein Drucker? Warum muss die da so ewig
drauf rumdrücken? Das ist ein Dings, das ist ein, das ist, ne, das ist so, wie nennt
man das? Die Drucker, die noch wie Schreibmaschine gedruckt haben, so Nadeldrucker oder so,
die haben, die einfach nur wie ne Schreibmaschine. Ja?
Die Omas kennen sich nicht aus hier. Most user friendly ist der Apple, sagt die Oma,
alles klar. Die wussten, die wussten damals schon Bescheid. Warum zeigen sie uns die Dudes
da in Großaufnahme? Naja, also das war, das war bei uns nicht so. Also ich kann mich noch
dran erinnern, dass ich früher, also als man, als man noch in Geschäfte gegangen ist und
sich Computer gekauft hat und sowas, ich habe da fast zu 90% schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht
und wisst ihr was der beschissenste, die gibt, die gibt es nicht mehr oder glaube ich, dass
die nicht mehr gibt. Wisst ihr was meiner Meinung nach die beschissenste Computerkette
aller Zeiten war? Phobis. Kennt noch einer Phobis von euch? Ich kann es ja jetzt mal schreiben.
Phobis. Die waren so richtig schlecht. Kennt noch jemand Phobis? Oder wie es die coolen
Leute damals ganz anders, Wo bis? Ey Phobis, so ein absoluter Kackladen. Gibt es die noch?
Die gibt es noch, ich habe noch ewig keinen Phobis gesehen. 13 Filialen. Aber gibt es,
gibt es, es gibt Phobis noch? Ernsthaft, diese Kackladen gibt, ich habe gedacht sie sind
schon längs Pleite. Warum gibt es diesen Scheißladen noch? Phobis. Okay, unsere Story Phobis Filialen
Hardware. Hey Max, weißt du vielleicht wie dieser Kabelball heißt, was die in dem Rechenzentrums
benutzt haben? Ich habe, ich weiß nur noch, dass das so ein Kabel, ich weiß nicht wie
das hieß, das war so was wo man Kabel besser ordnen konnte, also Kabel irgendwie gleich
lang ziehen und so. Ich habe keine Ahnung wie das Ding genau heißt. Okay Dienstleistung,
Beratung, alles klar. Ja genau, genau dazu gehe ich natürlich zu Phobis. Ach so, die
Seite ist ja absolut, finden sie jetzt ihre Filiale, okay. Okay es gibt, es gibt kein,
es gibt kein Phobis mehr, das ist im Prinzip einfach nur noch Überbleibsel. Es gibt 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, es gibt, nee Moment, ich habe mich, ich habe mich verzählt, es gibt 6 Phobis
Filialen in Deutschland auch, ganz toll, exzellent. Das haben sie aber auch verdient. Das ist
so dermaßen kacke. Zumindest warum ich Phobis so scheiße finde, muss ich vielleicht mal
kurz mal in 2 Minuten erzählen. Die haben, also erstens war das der unfreundlichste Laden
aller Zeiten in Hanau, der Phobis. Da hattest du das Gefühl, wenn du da reingehst, du bist,
du musst quasi, du bist so gesegnet vom Phobis, wenn die dich überhaupt wahrnehmen in dem
Laden. Also du konntest quasi, oder das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so eine Phobis Geschichte,
aber bestimmt hat das jeder schon mal erlebt, dass er in irgendeinen Laden reingegangen
ist, früher als man noch in Läden gehen musste und ist da 10 Minuten, 15 Minuten, 20 Minuten
drin rumgelaufen, hat nach irgendeinem Typ geguckt, der sich um einen kümmert und es
kam keiner und die haben dann teilweise sogar absichtlich weggeguckt, wenn du vorbeigelaufen
bist und sowas. Richtig, richtig Kacklehnen, die haben es nicht anders verdient, dass Amazoni
fertig macht. Ich kann es auch teilweise nicht nachvollziehen, wenn man, dass da so, dass
da so drüber rumgeheult wird. Ich meine klar, Amazon ist nicht alles gut und Amazon ist
an sich jetzt auch keine, die retten auch nicht die Welt oder so. Amazon ist ein Laden,
dem alles am Arsch vorbeigeht, solange die Kohle stimmt, vor allem das eigene, quasi
die Wohl der Mitarbeiter, aber die mal rein aus Konsumersicht, das ist bei Amazon einfach
angenehm. Du bestellst das, du kriegst das, du kannst einfach wieder zurückschicken,
was für ein Riesenakt das teilweise noch in Offline-Läden gewesen ist, wenn du was
umtauschen wolltest und sie dann gesagt haben, es geht nicht oder du kriegst so einen Gutschein.
Komplett bescheuert. Und die haben es die letzten 30 Jahre nicht geschafft mit der
Zeit zu gehen, da haben sie es nicht besser verdient. Wenn man nicht angesprochen werden
wollte, ist ja okay, aber wenn man aktiv durchgelaufen ist und geguckt hat, wo mal einer ist und
sich dann, zumindest in Phobis, ich hab mal, ich hab mal bei Phobis einen, weiß gar nicht,
ob ich den Drucker dort gekauft hab oder nur die Druckerpatrone. Ich glaube, ich hab nur
die Druckerpatrone gekauft und da bin ich heimgegangen und der Drucker hat mit der Druckerpatrone
schlieren gedruckt. Hab ich gesagt, okay, vorher mit der alten Patrone ging es, die
Patrone ist kaputt. Und habe ich die Patrone genommen, bin dann zum Phobis, meine Mutter
damals noch zusammen, zurück zum Phobis gefahren, haben gesagt, hier, die Patrone ist kaputt,
die druckt schlieren. Dann hatten die keinen Drucker da. Man muss sich mal vorstellen,
wie schwer die einem das Leben gemacht haben. Die hatten keinen Drucker da, der diese Patrone
fressen konnte, um es auszuprobieren. Und haben die gesagt, es muss am einen Drucker
liegen, ich kriege das Geld nicht wieder. Hab ich gesagt, wollen die mich verarschen,
die Patrone ist im Arsch. Könnt ihr euch einfach sagen, hier, gibt's nicht, wir haben euch
Kacke verkauft. Dann wollten die damals von uns, dass wir nochmal heimfahren, dass ich
meinen Drucker einpacke, mit dem Drucker zum Phobis komme und live dem zeige, dass seine
Druckerpatrone kaputt ist. Das ist ein Laden, der fuckt mich heute, wenn ich daran denke,
immer noch so ab, dass ich ihn gönne, pleite zu gehen. Und sie sind ja auch schon, sie
sind ja auch schon, sie sind ja auch schon am Arsch. Absolut, absolut verdient. Der größte
Scheißladen aller Zeiten. Also, wer, wer, die haben echt die, die komplett die Kontrolle
überleben verloren, die Jungs damals beim Phobis. Und, ähm, wie gesagt, dann hat das
jemand, dann hat der Drucker dort auch schlieren gedruckt. Und dann hat er eine neue Patrone
reingemacht und die hat halt keine schlieren gedruckt. Und, äh, da hab ich halt zu ihm
gemeint, aber das weiß ich nicht, ob ich gesagt hab, sollen wir jetzt das Geld wiedergeben,
ich will mit diesem Laden nichts mehr zu tun haben. Und das wollte er nicht, da wollte
er erst die Patrone austauschen. Was er ja auch darf, was er ja auch darf, dann bin ich
vergessen, ne. Ähm, ja. Euronics, ja Euronics, auch so ein Kackladen. Ähm, wo ich, wo ich,
ähm, auch, was war das denn? Radio, Radio irgendwas. Ah, ich hab vergessen, wie das
heißt. War das, war das der Saturn? Mediamarkt oder Saturn? Eins, ich glaub eins von beiden
war. Macht ja, macht ja keinen Unterschied, ist ja alles der gleiche Krämpel. Ähm, da
wollte ich auch damals ein Monitor kaufen, also noch hier so ein, sowas da. Alter, was
ist das? Der Pedobeermonitor oder was ist hier? So ein, so ein Ding da, so ein fettes
Teil wollte ich damals kaufen. Und, äh, da war ich glaube im Saturn oder Mediamarkt,
ich weiß nicht mal genau, was das, was das für ein Laden war. Zumindest bin ich da rein,
hab gesagt, hier, das war noch zu Zeiten, wo man sich gefreut hat, wenn man, wenn man,
äh, so mehr als 75 Hertz Monitor hatte. Und, ähm, wahrscheinlich ist das jetzt eine Frage,
die ins Leere geht, weil die wenigsten das von euch denk ich mal bewusst ausprobiert
haben. Ab wann, ab wann seht ihr kein Flimmern mehr auf CRT-Monitoren, Leute? Also bei mir
ist es wirklich erst so richtig gut ab 85 Hertz gewesen. Die meisten Leute denken sich
jetzt, Alter, Max, von was, von was spricht er, ja? Also ich, ich hab erst so ab ungefähr
85 Hertz kein Flimmern auf CRT-Monitoren mehr gesehen. Und das konnte man ganz gut erkennen,
wenn man einen weißen Hintergrund gemacht hat und hat dann nicht direkt auf den Monitor
geguckt, sondern so, so ein bisschen oben drüber. Dann hat man das ganz, ganz gut erkannt, wie,
wie flimmern. Und ich, bei mir war halt das Bild auf einem CRT-Monitor erst so richtig,
ist, ist richtig nice. Sorry, Boomer, ja? Erst so richtig stable bei 85 Hertz. Dann bin
ich damals in den Mediamarkt oder Saturn gegangen und hab dann halt gesagt, hier, ich brauch
einen Monitor, mindestens 17 Zoll oder mindestens 15, ich weiß nicht, was es war. Und, ähm,
halt 85 Hertz. So, da kam so ein Typ an und meinte so, wir haben den perfekten Monitor
für Sie hier, äh, 15, 15 Zoll, ganz, ganz toll, ergonomisch, super. Und da guck ich
mir das halt so an und meinte, ja Moment, der hat aber nur 75 Hertz. Ich hab doch gesagt,
ich will was mit mindestens 85 Hertz. Und dann hat er mit mir diskutiert, wo wir auch
wieder beim, beim Scheißladen sind, dass viele Geschäfte es einfach nicht besser verdient
haben. Dann hat er mit mir diskutiert, dass es nicht sein kann. Das war übrigens lustigerweise
damals schon ein Thema, dass es nicht sein kann, dass man überhaupt mit einem Auge mehr
als 75 Hertz braucht. Heute, Leute, heute, heute, heute ist es, das menschliche Auge
sieht nicht mehr als 25 FPS, ja? Und damals war es, das menschliche Auge braucht keine
Wiederholrate als 75 Hertz. Naja, und, da musste ich mit dem Typ damals diskutieren
und dann habe ich gesagt, nein, ich will doch gesagt, ich will keine 75 Hertz, ich will
mindestens 85 Hertz. Und da hat er, da hat er es dann nicht geglaubt, so. Dann, dann
war, du musst dir mal vorstellen, was für arrogante Spasten in so einem Laden haben.
Da hat er mir das nicht geglaubt und wollte mir dann kein Monitor empfehlen, da irgendwie
richtig hängen geblieben. Zumindest bin ich dann in andere Laden gegangen und hab dann,
das war glaube ich so das letzte Mal, wo ich mich so richtig offline in so einem Laden
von einem Verkäufer habe beraten lassen. Danach habe ich mir gedacht, weißt was, leck mich
aber ab. Ähm, ich glaube kurz danach habe ich mir auch mein erstes CT-Abo abgeschlossen
oder so. Ich hab, ich hab, ich bin ja schon ewig CT-Abonnent seit, frag mich nicht, seit
1996 oder so, da kam die erste CT raus. Und ich hab's heute immer noch, obwohl ich nicht,
nicht mehr lese. Das ist auch total hängen geblieben, ne? Ich hab, wie gesagt, seit,
seit keine, ja hier, ähm, ja ich sag mal, ich hab seit 97 oder so ein CT-Abo, also sprich
seit 23 Jahren und seit 10 Jahren, also lese ich's gar nicht mehr, ich hab's immer noch,
total hängen geblieben. Die liegen einfach nur rum, ich hab mir einen riesen Stapel,
das geht, das sind drei Stapel quasi fast vom Boden bis fast zu, ja bis auf die Höhe
vom Schrank. Nur CTs der letzten 23 Jahre übereinander, total hängen geblieben. Ich
guck da nie rein, ich lese die neuen nicht, aber ich hab das Abo immer noch. Richtig,
richtig bescheuert. Muss die einscannen, ne, die gibt's sogar online, kann man die sogar
online angucken. Ja ja, ich weiß, dass die online gibt's, du musst sie nicht einscannen.
Ähm, so, und das war das letzte Mal, wo ich mich beraten lassen hab von, von so einem,
von so einem Hersteller, danach hab ich immer selbst geguckt und danach hatte ich mir einen
Monitor gekauft mit 17 Zoll, 85 Hertz von einem Hersteller, von dem hab ich davor und
danach nie wieder was gehört. Ich weiß, heute noch wieder heißt Monitor, äh, Yakumo, nie
wieder, ich kenn diesen Hersteller nicht. Davor nie was von gehört, danach nie was von gehört,
keine Ahnung was das für ein Hersteller ist. Yakumo, ja, den hatte ich, den hatte ich jahrelang,
85 Hertz, 17 Zoll und glaub, äh, maximal Auflösung 1600 mal, weil was hatte, Moment, was war
das damals für eine Auflösung, die man hatte, 1600 mal 1200, ne? Ja, 1600 mal 1200. Die
CT ist doch nicht so cool, ja das stimmt, die EX ist besser, aber ich les weder CT noch
CT, ich hab halt das CT Abo schon ewig. Das hab ich aber noch, wie gesagt, halt aus Zeiten,
also erstens keine Ahnung, ob es so EX überhaupt schon gab und das war damals noch zu big brain
für mich. Und mittlerweile les ich ja gar nichts mehr davon, aber ich hab's einfach
und, äh, bestell's nicht ab, was richtig hängen geblieben ist, ne? Ich müsste eigentlich,
ich müsste eigentlich schon längst mal abbestellen. Es kostet, es kostet nicht so viel, was kostet
ein CT Abo im Jahr. Was kostet denn das? Das ist nicht so teuer. Ne, okay. Also im Prinzip
geb ich 140 Euro, aber Moment, ich hab, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich davon hab. Ich glaube,
ich hab das aber bezahlt, nur das kann das sein. Die haben nämlich irgendwann mal das
Heft Abo umgestellt und man hat, ähm, ne Login bekommen für dieses Digitalheise. Das kann
sein, dass es das gab für Leute, die schon über 10 Jahre dabei waren oder so. Ja. Das
ist, ich könnt mich immer wieder übelst reinsteigern, wenn ich, wenn ich mich über
Offline, über Offline-Läden aufregen muss.
Hast du schon PS5 Series X und neue Grafikkarten vorbestellt? Ja, was ich vorbestell, also was
ich versucht hab vorzubestellen, ist das hier. Aber hast ja keine Chance, ne? Hast ja absolut,
absolut gelitten. Ich wollte, ich wollte so eine vorbestellen, beziehungsweise bestellen
ging nicht. Äh, vorbestellen kann man, weiß gar nicht, ob man, kann man aktuell überhaupt
Sachen irgendwo vorbestellen? Das steht doch eh überall, out of stock kommt irgendwann
mal. Die sind aber auch frech geworden hier bei Alternator. Normalerweise kostet 1300-1400.
Ja, und PS5 und Series X hab ich nicht vorbestellt. Kann man, kann man die PS5 schon vorbestellen?
Ja, das schon. Will ich auch gar nicht. Ich kauf mir, ich kauf mir zu dem Release keine
aktuelle Konsolengeneration. Ich hab mir zum Release das letzte Mal die Xbox One gekauft
und eine PS3, äh eine PS4 gekauft und ich hab nichts davon benutzt. So richtig. Nix.
Ich hab die paar Stunden an beide, beide Konsolen. Komplett unsinnig, dass ich mir die gekauft
hab. Die größte Geldverschwendung aller Zeiten. Ach guck mal, hier gibt's ja angeblich
was. Heißen die wirklich 0815.eu? Ist aber ein ziemlich bescheuerter Name. Aber die haben
ultra huge Bewertungen, Alter. eBay, Deals Corner Shop. Ja, klingt äußerst verlockend.
Deals Corner Shop, das da zu kaufen. Ja, so sieht's aus, Ebaro. Ich muss ja kurz Chat
durchgucken, ich hab zig Sachen übersehen. Blöde Idee, teste doch mal das Oracle Linux
aus. Nee, das muss ich nicht testen, das haben wir auf der Arbeit auf ein paar Datenbanken.
Das ist ein ganz normales Red Hat clone mit ein paar Oracle Patches. Der Vorteil ist,
dass Support, dass Oracle Support Sachen teilweise nur unterstützt werden unter Oracle Linux
und teilweise billiger sind unter Oracle Linux. Und ich, zumindest war das vor ein paar Jahren
so, ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch so ist, weil Oracle Lizenzbedingungen blickt hier
echt keiner mehr durch. Äh, war es so, dass wenn man Oracle DBs virtualisieren möchte,
dann geht das nur sinnvoll unter Oracle Linux, weil ansonsten bezahlt man pro CPU, pro virtuellem
CPU Core und nicht pro CPU Core, irgendwie so. Lizenzbedingungen 2020. Passiert heute
noch, wenn du in Notebooks billiger Store reingehst. Was Notebooks billiger hat? Offline
Stores? Wirklich? Drextream sagt, er hatte damals einen alten PC von seinem Vater, der
hatte 45 Hertz. Das gibt es nicht. Das kleinste, was es gegeben hat, waren auf Fernsehern sowas
wie 50 Hertz bei PAL, aber 45? Moment, Moment, du meinst du 45 Megahertz CPU, nicht den Monitor?
Oder meinst du vielleicht wirklich 45 Hertz? Aber das wäre viel zu langsam. Ja, genau,
Sebaro, das ist doch was für dich, guck mal hier. Ja, haben wir uns vorher angeguckt,
da warst du noch nicht da und da habe ich noch gesagt, das ist bestimmt was für den
Sebaro. Arduino Uno Weeb Edition. Gut, aber die Arduinos sind ja mittlerweile, weiß ich
nicht, also die sind fett und die haben kaum RAM, kaum Flash, kaum CPU. Da würde ich jedes
Mal einen ESP32 oder so vorziehen. Ist nicht teurer. So, jetzt gucken wir mal ein paar
Videos. Hab gehört, die PS5 soll erst wieder im Februar verfügbar sein. Ja, können sie
machen. Ja Sebaro, das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Riecht wie eine Phänobär Beschreibung. Das
ist mir egal, ob die PS5 erst wieder im Februar verfügbar ist. Die können machen, was sie
wollen. Ich kaufe mir erst mal keine. Das war so so extreme übertriebene Fehlinvestition
das letzte Mal, dass ich mir eine PS4 und eine Xbox One gekauft habe. Ich hatte in der
Zeit, ungelogen, ich hatte öfters meine Xbox 360 an, als die Xbox One und einfach nur,
weil ich ein paar olle Dinger gespielt habe. Aber das kam mir dann backwards, backwards
compatibility und so gedönnt. Ok, warum Computer an Schach scheitern? Ich behaupte, sie scheitern
nicht an Schach. Sondern sie können das besser als Menschen aktuell spielen. Der AliExpress
PC. Leute, taugt das? Ich weiß, wir haben hier Linus Tech-Tipps, Abos, Subs. Lohnt sich
das anzugucken. In letzter Zeit muss ich sagen, waren wenig Videos dabei, die ich spannend
fand. Raspberry Pi Projects. Computer explodes. Leute, ich predikte jetzt mal was. Der Computer
explodet nicht. Das höchste der Gefühle, das ist bestimmt mega Clickbait Titel. Das
höchste der Gefühle, was passiert ist, dass er anfängt zu rauchen. Wollen wir wetten?
Wir wetten um 5 Subs. Der Computer explodiert nicht. Das höchste, was passiert ist, rauchen
oder vielleicht platzen ein paar Spannungswattler ab oder platzen ein paar Dinger drauf. Aber
er wird nicht explodieren.
Sind die bescheuert? Ist da mal einer auf die Idee gekommen, dass man einfach den Strom
rausziehen kann? Einfach den Strom aus der Steckdose ziehen. What the fuck? Was gibt
das, wenn es fertig ist? Die müssen einfach den Strom aus der Steckdose ziehen, das Netzteil
anschalten und dann den Strom wieder einstecken oder einschalten. Du musstest doch Netzteil
noch nicht mit einem Stück Holz einschalten. Naja. Oh mein Gott. Jesus Christ. Er geht
an. Er geht an. Oh mein Gott. Der Rechner. Der geht an. Ein Lüfter dreht sich. Jesus
Christ. Was ist das für ein bescheuertes Video? Nein, der Lüfter dreht sich. Wow. Ja gut,
das ist irgendein Kondensator kaputt gegangen oder so. Das ist doch nicht explodiert. Das
ist doch nicht explodiert. Jetzt ist doch nicht explodiert. Da ist irgendein Kondensator
geplatzt oder so. Was ist das für ein Netzteil? Bestimmt irgendwie LC Power China Netzteil.
Was ist das? Sieht man, was das für ein Netzteil ist? Das ist irgendein billig China Netzteil,
oder? Okay, wenn das ein ordentliches Netzteil wäre, dann würde das draufstehen. Enhance.
Okay, Moment. Moment. Enhance. Wir enhanceen jetzt. Windows Enhance. Ah, excellent. Alles
klar. Jetzt ist es viel besser. Jetzt erkennt man gleich viel mehr. Ah, yes. Jetzt ist alles
klar. Jetzt ist... Jetzt ist klar, oder? Also vorher hat man nichts erkannt, aber jetzt
erkennt man alles. Gut. Nein, nein, Chad. Hier nichts. Das war keine Explosion. Das zählt
das zählt nicht. Stimmt. Ja, CSI hätte das hingekriegt. Aber CSI hätte das noch besser
hingekriegt. Die hätten das Netzteil reingezoomt, dann hätten sie erkannt, dass sich der Ring
von dem Techniker spiegelt, hätten auf den Ring des Technikers gezoomt und hätten dann
erkannt, dass nebendran im Zimmer einer gerade auf dem Klo sitzt und kackt. Das wäre die
CSI-Zoom-Geschichte gewesen. Nee, dafür gibt es... Chad, dafür gibt es keine Subs. I paid Amazon
to upgrade my computer. It's a scam. Moment, das haben wir doch schon. Haben wir das nicht
schon mal geguckt? Ja, das haben wir schon mal geguckt, Alter. Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nein. Das haben wir schon ein paar Mal geguckt. Das kommen wir uns... Nein, nein, nein. Okay,
das ist, glaube ich, langweilig. AliExpress-PC. Okay, was machen die da? Tan-Bazaar. Alles
klar. Shenzhen, oder wo? Tan-Bazaar. Oder ist es Tan-Bar-SSH? Wie langweilig das funktioniert
sogar? Das RGB sieht aber doch ein bisschen unzusammenhängend aus, ne? Dort da ne Farbe,
dort da ne Farbe und da noch mal andere Farben. Okay, nee, das Video ist wirklich taug'nix.
Muss man nicht gucken. Raspberry Pi Projects. Desktop-PC. Okay, langweilig. Network Storage
Server. Gerade ein Raspberry Pi für einen Network Storage Server ist total bescheuert.
Selbst der Vierer taugt dafür nicht wirklich. Wi-Fi... Monka... What the fuck? Ja, Hangman,
so sieht's aus. Bad Company 2, bester Rush Mods. Was zum Geil macht der da? Was, was macht
der da? Erscheint mir auch wieder absolut nicht sinnvoll, aber mal gucken. Okay, Batterie
mit dem Raspberry Pi. Wie lang läuft das? Zehn Stunden oder so, dann ist aus. Wenn's
hochkommt. Man könnte dafür auch einfach einen 15 Euro TP-Link Access Point nehmen.
In Client-Modus setzen und gut ist. Das würde besser funktionieren als mit dem Raspberry
Pi. Manche Sachen muss man nicht bauen einfach nur weil man sie bauen kann. Ich mein, ich
bin ja auch immer dafür Sachen zu bauen, weil sie gehen. Ich mein, wir haben so einen
eigenen Mini-HTTP Server mal programmiert. Ich mein, es gibt genug Web-Server, ja? Es
ist ja nicht so, dass man... Aber das erscheint mir jetzt auch nicht sinnvoll. Also, wenn
man das machen will, weil man wissen will, wie es geht, okay, aber das jetzt so zu verkaufen
irgendwie als wäre es mal sinnvoll, das habe ich so meiner Zweifel dran. Nehmen wir einen
billig TP-Link Access Point für 15 Euro. Irgendwas ganz... Was ist der billigste TP-Link Access
Point, den es gibt? Viel zu teuer. 28 Euro, viel zu teuer. So was richtig billiges brauche
ich. Was ist der billigste Access Point, den man gerade so kriegt? Also, was, was, was
wirklich cool ist für den Preis, ist das da? Das ist wirklich Poggers, was man für den
Preis kriegt. 26 Euro. Du kriegst einen, du kriegst einen Access, MikroPick, MikroTick
Access Point, komplett mit Hooter, OS und allem für 23 Euro. Ich mein, gut, große Sprünge
kannst du damit nicht machen, kann auch kein 5 GHz WLAN. Was ist denn der billigste Access
Point, den man so kriegt? Das müssen wir jetzt gerade mal schauen. Hardware, irgendwie
Netzwerk, Access Points. So und da jetzt der Bill... Hier, Level 1 WAP, alles klar. 5x100
WAP. Okay, ganz so schlecht vielleicht doch nicht. Nettes E1 Plus, ach es wird immer
so scheiße. Hier, TP-Link, exzellent. Der billigste, den billigsten TP-Link Access Point,
alles klar, den brauchen wir. Hier, so. Dann ist es besser, man nimmt so ein, als statt
sich so ein Raspberry Pi Ding mit einer Powerbank selbst zu bauen. Warum ist denn das so gestreift?
Ist das einfach nur ein kack Foto oder hat das wirklich so Tarnfarben drauf? Hast du
den Among Us Clip mit Commander Krieger gesehen? Da, wo ihm das Fenster gegen den Kopf fällt?
Ja, das hab ich gesehen. Das hab ich gesehen. Das war schon geiles Timing. Guck mal, es
gibt sogar ein billiges, ein billiges Mikrofon. Okay, da wäre das, das hier meine, meine.
Oha, sieht das, das sieht aus wie 1998. Gut, da gab es noch kein Access Point, aber. Oha,
sogar wie EP, exquisite. Okay, das ist wirklich, das ist, das ist mal wirklich. Ziemlicher
Schrott. Zumindest alle mal besser, als das selbst zu bauen. Hast du die Memes dazu gesehen?
Netflix Intro? Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen. Ich kenne nur den Original Clip, wo ihm das
Fenster gegen den Kopf gefallen ist. Den kriegste bestimmt auch an der Powerbank dran.
Trump schreibt gerade folgendes, dass das ZigBee Thermostat, was wir uns angeguckt
haben letztens bei Amazon jetzt auch unter 40 Euro ist. Ja, wie, wie, ich hab ja am Anfang
des Streams gesagt, ich hab mir mal testweise eins bestellt und das ist das hier. Ich hab
es mir auch bei Amazon bestellt, weil bei AliExpress dauert es so lang. Ich glaube immer noch nicht,
dass es was taugt, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hab da meine Zweifel, ob es was taugt, aber ich
werde es mal ausprobieren, weil wenn das was taugt, kann ich mir da bei AliExpress für
19 Euro welche, für 19 Dollar oder 19 Euro oder 29 Dollar was gekostet hat, welche bestellen.
Dann kaufe ich mir halt einfach mal 8 Stück, dann kriegt jeder Heizung eins. Aber ich
habe noch Zweifel, ob das was taugt. Was ich gut finde an dem Thermostat ist halt, dass
es, gut, da hat eine Anzeige gefahren, aber dass du wohl drehen kannst, das finde ich
praktischer als mit irgendwelchen Knöpfen. Probier ich, ich werde es nächste Woche, das
können wir sogar mal im Stream ausprobieren, probier ich nächste Woche aus, ob das taugt.
Wenn nicht, schicke ich es einfach wieder zurück an Amazon. So, okay, jetzt was erzählt
er uns denn jetzt hier, warum das so geil ist, das mit dem Raspberry? Ich meine, guckt
euch mal diese komische, diese komische Konstruktion an. Der hat einen Raspberry Pi, ne, doch,
da unten, oder? Da unten einen Raspberry Pi, eine Powerbank. Und was ist das da oben drauf?
Da fuck. Warum hat er da oben nochmal was dran mit Antenne, warum nimmt er nicht jetzt
das Wi-Fi vom Raspberry Pi? Verstehe. Das ist komplett sinnlos. Ja, genau, okay, total
sinnlos. Radio, Object Detection, okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, aber einfach nur
der Raspberry Pi, wo die Kamera was erkennt, ist auch ziemlich unsinnig. Das muss schon
irgendwie integriert sein, also sprich, das muss dann schon irgendeine MQTT-Nachricht schicken,
irgendwelche Urls aufrufen können, wenn was passiert, weil wer läuft mit dem Raspberry
Pi durch die Wohnung und freut sich, dass was highlightet wird, ne, das ist ja so. Das
werde ich übrigens mit meiner Mülltonne machen. Das werde ich mit meiner Mülltonne machen.
Der Chat hat mich auf die Idee gebracht. Der Chat hat mich jetzt ernsthaft, das ist wirklich
mal was, wo der Twitch-Chat mal wieder, mein Twitch-Chat ist ja eh exquisite big brain,
wo der Twitch-Chat wieder richtig schlau gewesen ist. Und zwar, ich habe ja letztens was gesucht,
wo man, wie ich erkennen könnte, ob der Müll abgeholt wurde und ich mache einfach Object-Erkennung
mit der Kamera. Ich habe eine Kamera am Hoftor und ich kann einfach erkennen, wenn die Mülltonne
da steht und das muss ich mal gucken, das werde ich irgendwie trainieren, dass er meine
Mülltonnen, die drei Mülltonnen erkennt und da kommen die Mülltonnen einfach immer
auf die gleiche Position, sodass die Kamera die sieht. Und wenn sich die Mülltonne bewegt,
dann ist die Müllabfuhr da gewesen. YOLO V3, ja, das kenne ich, gibt es nicht mittlerweile
sogar YOLO V4. By the way, was hat das mit dem Darknet zu tun, Triol? Das ist ein ganz
normales Open-Source-Guitar-Projekt, YOLO. Das hat mit Darknet doch überhaupt nichts
zu tun, aber Darknet klingt natürlich besser, ja. Ach so, ach, das ist Darknet für das Frame?
Okay. He lacks critical information. He doesn't know. Ja, das hier. Da gibt es sogar.net-Bindings.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nur YOLO V3. Guck, da kann man Object Detection machen. Ich glaube,
das werde ich mal ausprobieren, vielleicht machen wir das auch mal im Stream. Mit OpenCV
haben wir schon mal Motion Detection gemacht. Gerade war es gefunden. Thermostat Essentials,
das ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich. WeSmart, ach so. Okay, ja, werden wir mal ausprobieren.
Ich mache wahrscheinlich erst mal ZigBee2MQTT. Oder gucken wir mal. Moment, warum habe ich
so eine Musik gespeichert? Oh, ich habe schon viel mehr unter Musik gespeichert. Dabei
wollte ich das nie unter Musik speichern. Ich werde es mal ausprobieren, wenn es da
ist. YOLO. Hier gucken wir mal weiter. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Genau, also Raspberry
Pi Projekte. Also das für sich genommen war fragwürdig. Aber es ist schon mal gut,
das ist nice. Also wenn er den Keyboard erkennt in der Bewegung, dann erkennt er auch mal
eine Mülltonne. Mit was macht er das? Also der mag seine Raspberry Pi, ist gerne voll
gestopft mit Dinger. Okay, TensorFlow. Tablet. Okay, das ist unglaublich sinnlos, ein Tablet
aus dem Raspberry Pi zu machen. Dann kaufe ich mir lieber einen Fire HD an Weihnachten.
Ist jetzt übrigens Prime Day demnächst? Ah, zwei Tage, until Prime Day. Das muss ich
mal aufschreiben. 13 da ist Prime Day. Und ist am 13 nicht auch dieses Apple Event? Prime
Day gucken, da müssen wir ein paar Sachen einkaufen. Äh, Moment, Events. Ne, Apple 13. Weiß
jemand wieviel Uhr das ist? 10 am PDT zu CEST. Nein, nein, nicht zerst. 19 Uhr. Und
sind immer diese Zeitzonen kacke. Können wir nicht einfach alles in UTC machen? Ähm,
warum war ich denn jetzt auf Amazon? Ja genau, da kaufe ich mir lieber einen Fire HD 10
oder so, bevor ich ein Raspberry Pi Tablet baue. So und die gibt's, also die Fire HD 10s gibt's
an Weihnachten und Prime Day ist wahrscheinlich für 100. Oder einen Fire HD 8, die gibt's
für 50 Euro. So, da kannst du dich nicht beschweren. Also alle mal besser als, äh, äh, äh, äh,
als ein Raspberry Pi Tablet. Ich meine, ein Raspberry Pi hat Vorteile, ist ein vollständiges
Linux, man kann alles mögliche drauf machen im Vergleich zu einem Android. Allerdings
gerade für Tablets bauen, nehme ich einfach ein Tablet. Ich weiß, klingt jetzt, äh,
ne, Massive Big Brain, aber ein Tablet ist ein besseres Tablet als ein Android. Äh, als
ein Raspberry Pi. Gab's eigentlich Leaks, ob die neuen iPhones USB-C bekommen? Ne, keine
Ahnung, aber es wird mich sehr wundern. Apple mag doch ihr Lightning gedöhnt so. Das ist
eine gute Idee. Da sind verschiedene Projekte. Bilderkennung hat er, Bilderkennung, äh, passt's.
Was ist ne Pirate Box? Was ist ne Pirate Box? Aha. Also, Monka Toss in Deutschland. Irgendwelches
Air Traffic, äh, Zeug, juck mir nicht. Hardware Wallet, brauche ich auch nicht. Nintendo Emulator
ist klar, kannst du mit so ziemlich alle machen. Christmas Lights Controller würde ich nicht
im Raspberry Pi machen. Das mache ich mit dem ESP32 für meinen Weihnachtsbaum. Ähm,
tja, ok. Siehste, wie ich mir gedacht hab, keine dollen Sachen dabei. Installing Windows
10 on RAM. So, überspringen wir das Ganze mal. Am Ende hat er es im RAM installiert. Und
was passiert, wenn der Rechner Rebootet? Also, Windows 10 im RAM ist ziemlich, ziemlich unpraktisch.
Windows 10 hat hier die Angewohnheit mal öfters zu rebooten. Was macht man denn, wenn Windows
rebootet? Ist dann, ist dann RAM-Disc weg. Server Homelab für weniger als 1000 Euro.
Ok, das können wir uns angucken. Ich läste ja immer gerne über die Aufbau von anderen
Leuten, um ein bisschen von meinem Zeug abzulenken. Äh, die iPads. Bei iPads wollen sie wahrscheinlich
auch, dass du da zig Peripheriesachen anschließen kannst. Aber gerade bei iPhones finden sie
ihr Lightning Zeug doch unglaublich geil. Also, ich hätte keine Schmerzen mit, ich fände
sogar gut, wenn es USB-C wäre. Weil aktuell brauche ich immer Adapter. Entweder Micro-SD,
Micro-USB-C oder Lightning. Und ich hätte kein Problem, wenn es nur noch Micro-USB und
USB-C wäre. So, gucken wir uns das mal an. Was haben wir sonst noch? Ok, da habe ich jetzt
noch einen. Das macht er nicht einfach so aus dem Kopf, oder? Da hat er bestimmt irgendeinen
Plan. Und dann mit Zeitraffer, bzw. Schnitt. Die ganzen, die ganzen Lego-Teile hätte ich
gar nicht. Ich habe noch, ich habe noch relativ viele Lego-Technik-Teile von früher, aber
nicht so diese advanceden Dinger. Also Federn habe ich noch, aber diese, diese Ketten und
so, pff, könnte ich überhaupt nicht bauen. Aber das sind ja auch die Lego-Pros, die haben
wahrscheinlich alle Lego-Teile, die weltweit jemals released wurden. Es passt, es passt,
es war dick ein Lego-Motor dran. Es fährt. Exzellent. Was gibt, das gibt das Rohr, das
gibt die Kanone. Nice. Also wenn du das mit ordentlich Schmackes gegen das Bein kriegst,
tut das wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen zwicken. Ok, ich glaube, das tut wirklich, das tut
sogar weh, wenn man das gegen das Bein kriegt aus der Nähe. Ich meine, das hat ordentlich
Niveau bis drauf. So ein Lego-Fußball hat jetzt nicht so viel Gewicht, aber ich glaube,
wenn du das wirklich mit vollem Schmackes gegen das Bein kriegst und keine Ahnung, du
läufst gerade in kurzer Hose durch die Wohnung und der ballert dir mit dem Panzer gegen die
Wade, das tut glaube ich schon ein bisschen, mehr als zwicken, das tut wahrscheinlich
sehr gut. Ah, exzellent, Knoten. Ah, das ist zum Laden, ok. Doch, ich glaube, das zieht
ordentlich, wenn man die Kugel abkriegt. Huge Brain. Jetzt will er es aber wissen, mit
Magazin hier. Guckt euch das mal an, das ist richtig so fistic, das ist richtig advanced
hier. Wo war hier? Da fehlt jetzt eigentlich bloß ein 6000 Grad heißer Lego-Panzer gegen
Cola-Flasche. Ok. Ich glaube, das tut weh, wenn man das gegen das Bein kriegt. Ich meine,
auf die Entfernung nicht mehr, aber wenn du direkt davor stehst. Ok, das gibt es jetzt,
dass man die Kanone hoch und runter, ne, doch, dass man die Kanone hoch und runter machen
kann. Das ist ja richtig nice. Das ist ja geil.
Ja, also so wie das geklatscht hat, wenn du das aus der Entfernung gegen das Bein kriegst,
dann tut es, glaube ich, echt ganz gut weh. Bam. Ja. Drüberfahren. Huge Slow-Mo. Ok,
also ich bleibe dabei, das tut doch weh, wenn das einem gegen das Bein schießt. Ich meine,
du musst erstmal die Dose verformen. Die sind nicht sonderlich stabil. Also es wird
nichts passieren, aber es tut doch ein bisschen weh. Das ist ja geil.
Vorgaskonstruktion. Ach, das ist der Channel, der auch diese ganzen schneidet Kartoffeln
und so Fabrik gebaut hat. Das habe ich aber schon mal angeguckt.
Jetzt, will er jetzt das Brot schneiden da drauf? Hast du das Lego U-Boot schon gesehen?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Wer macht das ganze Lego Zeug danach wieder sauber? Also jetzt
geht es ja noch, es ist Brot, aber wenn dann irgendwelche klebrigen Sachen kommen, das
pappt doch alles voll. Jetzt wird es geschnitten. Wird es jetzt geschnitten? Komm mal hier in
die Säge rein, in die Säge. Das ist ja richtig. Huge.
Meine Geschwindigkeit hält sich den Grenzen, aber es funktioniert. Womit er beim Thema
sein will, wer macht das Lego danach alles sauber? Aber echt, guck mal, es funktioniert.
Also, next level wäre noch, wenn er noch eine Lego Spülmaschine baut, die das danach
wieder sauber macht. Exquisite. Komm mal hier, sogar Schinke mit Salatblatt. Das da.
Was ist das da hinten? Aha, ein Stück Mozzarella oben drauf. Für Thunfisch ist es aber dann
schon fast zu rot. Exzellent. Okay, wir sehen ja klar, jetzt kommt ein roher Lachs drauf.
Was ist das? Paprika. Doch, das wird Paprika sein. Das ist bestimmt Paprika. Weißt du,
wieso man seit neuestem Uplog auf Twitch Werbung bekommt? Ja, weil Uplog die erste neue Version
braucht, die noch in der Entwicklung ist, dass es wieder blockt. Steht auch bei denen.
Ich mein, hier läuft man nicht die Gefahr, dass man sich irgendwie überfrisst, weil
das geht so langsam. Da isst man dann auch, dann isst man nur das Nötigste. Okay, was
ist das jetzt? Das ist bestimmt Paprika. Paprika Petersilie oder sowas. Ja, Paprika.
Die Musik dabei.
Salami. Ach stimmt, wir haben ja Salami-Emote, hab ich ja ganz vergessen. Oh Mann, aber
ich mein, es ist cool, dass das klappt. So unsinnig es ist, das ganze Zeug ist komplett
useless, aber das ist schon geil. Hat der auch die Lego-Beerprop, der hat alles möglich,
der hat auch, der Typ hat auch einen Lego-Schneeschieber und sowas. Also, die haben da wirklich viel
geiles Zeug. Zwar alles total unsinnig, aber cool anzugucken. Okay, wir gucken uns noch
ein bisschen Schlösser aufmachen an. AliExpress-Schloss. Ist das ein Schloss aus dem 3D-Trocker? Das
sieht ein bisschen so aus, oder? Das sieht aus wie aus dem 3D-Trocker, das Schloss. So
mit den unterschiedlichen Schichten. Was sagst du zum Opera GX Browser? Das haben wir vor
einem Jahr oder so mal ausprobiert und ich habe nichts gefunden, warum man den verwenden
sollte. Ein Plastikschloss, das klingt besonders sicher. Vor allem das Made in China macht
mich schon sehr zuversichtlich, dass es gut halten wird.
Oh, das ist aber ganz schön advances Feuerzeug hier. Das ist jetzt schon halber Bunsenbrenner.
Also ich hab als ich auf Jelly war, Chat wegen den Browsern. Es spricht überhaupt nichts
dagegen, mehrere Browser zu haben. Also ich hab aktuell hab ich Vivaldi installiert,
Chrome, Chromium, Firefox. Es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen einfach. Ja gut, Edge und Internet
Explorer sind dabei, lasse ich jetzt mal außen vor. Warum nicht? Gibt es eigentlich ein
gutes kostenloses VPN? Weiß ich nicht. Ich verwende eigentlich so gut wie keine VPNs.
Das einzige wo ich VPN verwende ist wenn ich beispielsweise mal irgendwelche DLCs früher
herunterladen will oder mir vielleicht doch mal irgendwas geoblocktes angucken will, aber
so gut wie nie. Also die beste Variante ist, wenn man sich, die erste Frage ist, braucht
man überhaupt einen VPN? Wenn man wirklich den Anwendungsfall hat, wo man einen VPN benötigt,
zum Beispiel wenn man Netflix gucken will im anderen Land oder so, dann kann man sich
überlegen ob man sich nicht den Anbieter nimmt oder aber man mietet sich irgendwo eine
OpenVM und installiert sich selbst einen Wireshark. Wie heißt das? Nicht OpenVPN? Ich hab's
nicht aufgepasst. Das hab ich nicht aufgepasst, ja. Kannst du mir Donat... Nee, ich hab Donation
ausgeschaltet nachdem der Link kaputt war. Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst natürlich
einen Sub holen auf Twitch oder einfach nur dir den Stream angucken und nichts machen.
Das ist eh die beste Variante. Das ist vier Jahre alt, ja. Das mach ich auch bei den
meisten Streams. Bei den meisten Streams lurke ich immer nur. Ich hab bei ganz wenigen Streams
Abos. Ich hab vielleicht, wenn's hochkommt, vier, fünf Twitch Abos. Diesen Monat hab
ich glaub ich gar keins gemacht. Diesen Monat hab ich gar keins. Aber ich hab dense gaming
hab ich öfters. Thronax YouTube, dankeschön. Excellent Subscription. Dense Gaming hab ich
sonst immer. Das ist der einzige Let's Player den ich mir angucken kann. Ja, genau der.
Der einzige wahre Copper Brite Let's Player auf Twitch. So jetzt wird's heiß gemacht.
Ja gut, wenn du das Schloss schmelzen kannst, ist schlecht. Vielleicht klüts.
Und jetzt bei mir, excellent Thronax. Willkommen im High IQ Club. Also eins muss man ja sagen,
was ich bei seinen Videos schon durchschaut habe ist, würde er das Schloss nicht aufbekommen,
gebe es kein Video dazu. Das heißt wir wissen, das geht gleich auf.
Also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die würde ich nicht bei AliExpress kaufen. So was, zum Beispiel
Batterien, wenn ich wirklich will, dass es sicher sein soll. Batterien, ist auch so was.
Würde ich nicht bei AliExpress kaufen. Batterien von AliExpress, hätte ich Angst, dass die
Monkers smoken demnächst. Moin Patrick. Und Technik Sachen, die einen schlechten Eindruck
machen und an 230 Volt angeschlossen werden, das kaufe ich mir auch nicht bei AliExpress.
Genau, Topics. Aber ansonsten, den Rest kann man. Sebaro, wenn das maximal 24 Volt hat,
dann kann man sich das überlegen. Und, aber Batterien ist so ein Ding, das würde
ich da nicht kaufen. Weil, im Zweifelsfall, fängt dir das Ding da noch an zu brennen.
Wieso hast du Vivaldi installiert? Weil ich den mal wieder ausprobieren wollte und seitdem
nicht. Moment, habe ich den noch installiert? Nee, habe ich nicht. Ich habe letztens den
Stream deinstalliert und ich habe gesagt, wir probieren den jetzt mal wieder aus, aber haben
wir nie gemacht. Ich hatte den die ganze Zeit installiert. Ja, weil es eigentlich ein ziemlich
cooler Chromverschnitt ist, Browser mit vielen Zugangsfunktionen, den ich ziemlich gut finde.
So im Geiste von dem alten, so ein bisschen Richtung, wie der alte Opera war. Aber ich
bin bis jetzt noch nicht dazu gekommen, mir das größer, länger mal anzugucken.
So, that's it for now with our plastic core Chinese laminated catalog. Excellent. If you
have any questions or comments, please put them below. If you like this video and would
like to see more like it, please subscribe. And as always...
Das lohnt, sei mal dahingestellt. Wenn man 1080p spielen will, lohnt es sich beispielsweise
auch nicht, sich eine 3090 RTX zu kaufen. Man kann immer unsinnig viel Geld ausgeben.
Plasma Saber Build. Ich gucke jetzt eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays. Easy. Hörst du mal
eine Runde Battlefield gucken. Was hörst du da im Hintergrund? Das da. Oh nee, es geht
ja schon wieder so los wie das letzte. Es geht ja schon wieder so los, wie das letzte
aufgehört hat er. Massivste Brain Gegner. Denkst du Big Navi wird krass? Also nachdem
ich die letzten AMD Grafikkarten mich jetzt schon nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt habe,
glaube ich nicht, dass jetzt von jetzt auf gleich irgendwie super krasser Konkurrenz
da für Nvidia entsteht. Rex, beste Pistole hier. Huge. Oh das ist aber ein geiler Clip.
Weil die Gegner sind schon ganz schön pepega, aber richtig geiler Clip. Kommt mal ein neues
Battlefield Jahr nächstes Jahr, glaube ich. Weiß nicht ob dieses Jahr noch irgendwas
ist. Ob dieses Jahr noch irgendwie ein Remake oder so kommt. Ja, 2020. Mal gucken. Mir ist
es, ohne Scheiß, mir ist es sogar lieber. Es kommt 2022. Also wenn es wirklich gut ist,
ist es mir lieber, es kommt später als unfertig. Die Sache ist nur die, ich hab meine Zweifel,
dass die wieder ein ordentliches Battlefield auf die Reihe kriegen werden. Ja, neues Testament
geht mir ähnlich. Es sieht aus wie Console Graphics, das ist ja 800 x 600, aber ich glaube
es sind keine Console Graphics. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16. M16.
M16. M16 Residenz Leaper. Residenz Leaper. Immerhin, die werden schon nice weggesprayt,
aber M16 hat man so viel schon gesehen.
Spray, Spray, Spray, Spray, so muss das sein. Schau dir mal Nate Kipsel an, sagt mir gar
nix. Beste Piskel.
Sieht aus, als hatte er ein Aimbot, hatte er aber nicht. Ist das quasi der Shroud von
Ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern, dass ich das mal länger als zwei Sekunden überlebt
hab, hier in der Mitte von Noshakannons oder drum zu iron. Eine Runde Metro. M16. Was sonst,
ne? Jetzt, ich hätte schon wieder Anschluss gekriegt auf YouTube jetzt. Max, warum revives
du deine Leute nicht? Null Teamplayer, warum kannst du so ein Gameplay zeigen? Das ist
doch, ja, ja. Max, beleb doch mal deine Teammates wieder. Max, beleb doch mal deine Teammates
wieder. Guck, guck, er meckert, er meckert auch. Huge. Massive. Oh, oh, er belebt sogar
wieder, alles klar. Okay, jetzt ist das Gameplay approved, jetzt darf man es zeigen. Spielt
der Kikona oder Kikomeriz? Ich glaub, da spielt Kikomeriz, oder? Wie sie nichts checken, Alter.
Die kapieren ja absolut wieder gar nichts. Crossplay sieht fast so aus, als hättest du
den Controller dran. Eine Runde Tunnel. Backrage. Bip. Der Typ ist afrikanisch, der
Typ ist afrikanisch, der Typ ist afrikanisch, der Typ ist afrikanisch. Der Typ ist afrikanisch,
Was macht der Gegner?
Er hat wahrscheinlich Einsersens, Einsersens, der kommt nicht vorwärts, äh.
Max gebt dir mal bitte eine Minute dieses Video.
Können wir machen.
Ceroxinu, 14 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, Alter das ist aber ein echt nicer Clip.
Das sieht man so selten in Rush, ich finde Noshark Cannons Rush ist jetzt vielleicht
nicht die beste Map aber ist auch mal ganz nett zwischendurch, man sieht es eigentlich
fast nur in TDM, P90, es gibt noch genug Spieler ja, aber du kriegst maximal 2-3 Server voll
zur Zeit, wir können gleich mal gucken, deswegen ist das der Terminator, wir hatten manchmal
auch einen Terminator hier in unseren Games, der war noch früher bei mir auf YouTube, ob
das der ist, da werden sie weggesprayt, ja Suppression ist eigentlich der größte Abfax
in Battlefield 3, aber man kann eine Sache dagegen machen, man muss, wenn man die Gegner
bashen will, ohne dass sie einbashen können, ist man muss Anti-Suppression mitnehmen.
Das schaltet die Suppression zwar nicht aus, aber man wird deutlich langsamer Suppressed
als sein Gegner und dein Gegner trifft dich nicht und du triffst ihn noch und jetzt Bam
die Panzer noch kaputt, jawoll, da hat er Glück gehabt, dass er noch umgefallen ist, ja,
das ist gut, von der anderen Seite ist aber auch gut, also generell hier die Pussy ist
top, Suppression in Battlefield 3 war die Geschichte, dass dein Bildschirm verschwimmt
und deine Waffe ungenauer wird, wenn die Gegner auf dich schießen und es ist nicht so, dass
es einfach nur verschwimmt, sondern dass du auch nicht mehr dahin schießt, wo du hin
zielst, das ist total random und bescheuert gemacht.
Ich mochte ja die Battlefield 3 Samples von den Soldaten immer, wie sie rumschreien, aber
es geht nichts über MW2 und zwar der hier, der ist so panisch am rumschreien.
Alter, da werden sie weggespreit, erstmal schön spotten durch den Smoke und alles weggespreit.
Thomas, cool, 6 Monate lang für den Sub, exquisite Subscription, Dankeschön, Alter,
die Gegner, die sind weggespreit, das waren bestimmt 25 Gegner jetzt, die er da weggespreit
hat.
Spaß, nee gar keine Spaß, 370, ja, weil die Gegner es wieder nicht gecheckt haben.
Was ist mit dem Dude los da oben?
Was ist mit dem Dude los?
Und jetzt nix wie raus hier, aus halber Team mittlerweile reingespornt da oben, okay kann
ich machen, mach ich, mach ich, mach ich, der war bei dem P-Crush, ja, Paul war's, Moment,
wie haben die da das erste Mal entschärft da unten, erstmal schön Muskel-Shirt in
der Webcam, exzellent, wer hat, der hat, ne, ganze Shotgun-Gameplay hier, die werden alle
danach zu Tode geflammt, zumindest früher auf der Xbox, werden alle mit dem Shotgun,
die ganzen Shotgun-Huts, die werden danach zu Tode geflammt, per Voice-Message, ich
glaube das geht mittlerweile nicht mehr, oder, früher konntest du ja Leuten Voice-Messages
schicken, einfach über Scoreboard, Scoreboard, Xbox-Profil, Voice-Message, was ich da für
bescheuerte Voice-Messages als gekriegt hab noch, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich geht
das mittlerweile gar nicht mehr, weil das, ähm, weil da die Leute zu, zu harassed werden.
Geht immer noch, okay, das stimmt, da hat er recht, die beschissenste Sache auf dieser
Map ist B, oder halt das, das, das hier, das hier, neben, ist, beschissenste Objektiv,
da kommst du gar nicht richtig rein, ooooh, ne, aber trotzdem noch ist ein Clip, oah,
Thronax ist schon ewig her, Happy Peaking, das ist ein krasser Flamer, den Typ, mit dem
haben wir auch mal gespielt, der ist übelst am Raging immer, Happy Peaking, ump, ich frag
mich immer, wie die so geile Runden hinkriegen, weil teilweise ist es, wenn ich in den Gang
gerannt werde, werde ich schon von drei Gegnern abgeaimt.
Oajajajajajajajaj, Gegner, schieß doch zurück, schieß doch zurück, schieß doch zurück,
ne P
O, ja wahrscheinlich, weil die Gegner in diesem Game war sozusagen kacke,
ein besser job
warte
suits
difficult
halt
Und
Also Chet, was sollte ich gucken? Ich hab mir zwei Sachen kopiert. Ich sollte mir mal irgendwas angucken.
Ich gucke mir das jetzt nacheinander an, wie es eingeschickt wurde.
Ich sollte mir erstmal das da angucken.
Kenn ich überhaupt gar nicht. Wer ist das?
Wer ist das? ExoGhost?
Ich kenne mich mit Call of Duty Channels absolut null aus.
Was haben wir für eine Sense? Das ist aber PC, oder?
Also entweder ist der nur sau schnell mit der Tastatur.
Wow, what the fuck?
Gut, wer hat Gegner, wer hat weggesprayt?
Ja ok, kann sein.
Ne, ne, das kann schon sein, das kann schon sein.
Ne, ne, das sieht legit aus.
Wie hat Gegner, wer hat weggesprayt? So.
Gut, da gab es jetzt nicht so viel zu sehen. Was sollte ich mir angucken?
Nate, was? Nate Gibson. Ok, habe ich auch noch nie gehört.
Aimbot-Mann.
Ok, gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht für Aimbot-Dings nicht so das beste, wenn man sich...
Ok, ok, ok, mal zurück.
MP5, ist das... Ne, das ist nicht... Was ist das?
Schau es dir von vorne an.
Ok, es sieht echt ein bisschen aus wie Aimbot, kenne ich euch recht.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es komplett ok, ja.
Also das schnelle, das schnelle Ding, das sah wirklich schon ein bisschen...
Ne, ne, ne, das passt, das passt.
Das, ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist jetzt auch, also das am Anfang war wirklich sehr zackig.
Ne, ne, ne, das ist alles vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich meine, die werden schon ordentlich gebashed, muss man sagen.
Aber die rennen ihm aber auch gerade mal richtig, richtig krass rein.
Man, the fuck, was ist mit denen los?
Das ist Crossplay mit Android, ja.
Und jetzt?
Es gibt also wirklich noch Leute, die den Multiplayer spielen, ja.
Das ist schon ziemlich on point, wie er oft...
Also man, der ist sau schnell auf den Gegnern, ohne irgendwie großartig zu übersteuern.
Also das ist echt nicht ohne, aber da ist halt, da ist nichts gehackt oder so.
Der kann das nur gut.
Oh nein, Glück gehabt.
Was holst du dir PCI 4M2 für deinen neuen PC?
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Erst mal gucken, irgendwas mit viel Speicher.
Klar, potenziell kannst du mit allem cheaten, aber das sieht jetzt nicht irgendwie großartig gecheatet aus.
Der kann halt seine Maus ordentlich bedienen.
Aber was man halt da dran merkt, ist, dass der auch schon sau viele Stunden drin hat,
weil er viele Sachen total automatisch macht, wie hier das Gegnerdings, Instant Knifed und so.
Da ist viel Übungssache drin.
Hab ich ja nicht gedacht, dass noch Leute Multiplayer spielen, der Multiplayer geht mir so auf den Sack.
Das ist auch nicht Multiplayer, das ist Ground War.
Nein, den Monitor filmen bringt nichts, man sieht die Maus.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass er das wirklich macht, als Anti-Cheat irgendwie.
Aber ich finde das jetzt nicht sonderlich verdächtig.
Der zielt halt einfach gut, das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, aber nach der Logik-Chat hat jeder, der was trifft, potenziell ein Aimboard an.
Klar, kann schon sein.
Ich weiß das nie. Aber ich finde das sieht vollkommen normal aus.
Trefft halt gut.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist Ground War das einzige, was man spielen kann.
Aha.
Das MW2 Gunship war so OP.
Du musstest ja nur ansatzweise in die Nähe der Gegner schießen und die waren tot.
Boah, die werden aber schon hart zerstört gerade.
Erstmal den Panzer bashen.
Ist schon nice.
Was mir gut gefällt ist, dass der wenigstens normal spielt und nicht so rumgammelt die ganze Zeit.
Das lässt sich echt ganz nice angucken.
Gibt es eigentlich in Cold War auch sowas wie Ground War bitte?
Ja, kann man sich gut angucken, der ist schön unterwegs, passiert was.
Siehst du mal, Modern Warfare könnte, wenn das Spiel eben die Leute dazu erbringen würde,
um sich mehr zu bewegen, könnte tatsächlich Spaß machen.
Aber die meisten Leute bewegen sich nicht.
Es ist ja auch schon mal keine normale Runde.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es bei ihm auch nicht jede Runde so läuft.
Ist halt bei Gameplay so, dass man nur das sieht, wo es besonders gut läuft.
Normalerweise würde er schon abgecampt werden aus irgendeinem Fenster wahrscheinlich.
Oder ist es so ein Ding, dass wenn man richtig viel Übung in Ground War hat, das irgendwie umgehen kann.
Aber da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Ich gucke mir ab und zu Huskers an, wenn der Dings hier Warzone spielt.
Der spielt auch extrem gut, aber wird teilweise so unsinnig weggecampt aus irgendwelchen Ecken.
Schauen wir mal das Sniper-Video an.
Ich finde, das kann man sich echt gut geben.
Der Sniper.
Der ist echt richtig pissed.
In your face.
There's one more here.
I want this Black Ops 4.
Finde ich auch schon ein bisschen schnell, dass es jetzt ein neues Black Ops gibt.
Ich meine es gab Black Ops, es gibt Modern Warfare und es gibt wieder Black Ops.
Hä?
Wollte ich nicht mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen, naja gut.
Was frage ich mich da überhaupt noch?
Hogger ist einfach zu einfach.
Paladin ist einfach zu einfach.
Er ist nicht einfach genug.
Charak denkt nicht so.
Ähm.
Ah, ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Nein, ah danke.
Da ist halt, da ist halt extrem viel Übungssache da.
Oh fuck, mein Tastatur ist wieder auseinander gefallen.
MonkaS, was mache ich denn jetzt?
Moment, ich muss erstmal die Knopf wieder dran machen.
Äh.
So.
Sledgehammer ist gefickt, ich habe das null verfolgt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da los ist.
Ähm, mich wundert es nur, dass schon wieder Black Ops am Start ist.
China Tastatur, AliExpress, ja.
AliExpress Tastatur.
Ok, ich lese da nochmal ein bisschen ab über Hardware von anderen Leuten.
Das mache ich doch immer gern.
Um nochmal auf Battlefield zurückzukommen.
Ok, Moment.
Komm, hier können wir kurz reingucken.
Ups, geht das jetzt nicht?
Was ist das da?
EU?
Ist das Baguette Stream?
Bam, bababam, bababam, bababam.
Ok, das ist so, wie man den Retard spielt, oder?
Du spannst einfach so wie ein Retard und du killst alle.
Das ist so, wie du spielst.
Die Webcam ist schief, ja.
Ja, das triggert.
Medaille repressielle, alles klar, alles klar.
Ja, es gibt in allen Games richtig gute Spieler.
Und es ist halt auch ein Unterschied.
Also es gibt erstmal einen riesen Unterschied zwischen so den 0-15-Bops, die so rumrennen.
Und meinen sie wären es voll und welchen die wirklich gut spielen.
Und dann gibt es auch den Unterschied zwischen welchen die wirklich gut spielen und welchen die richtig gut spielen.
Also man sieht halt einfach, wenn einer erstens in einem Game viel Übung hat, da machst du viele Sachen schon automatisch.
Und man merkt halt auch, wenn es einer skillmäßig richtig drauf hat.
Da ist halt verdammt viel Übungssache drin.
Also erstens brauchst du gescheites Equipment, das darf man natürlich auch nicht unterschätzen.
Und man muss den Scheiß grinden ohne Ende.
Es kann jeder halbwegs gut werden, wenn er ordentlich Zeit reinsteckt.
Ich meine, es wird nicht jeder irgendwie CS-Pro, das ist auch klar.
Aber jeder kann das halbwegs gut, wenn er Zeit reinsteckt.
Die meisten Leute denken, aber halt sie spielen 5 Stunden und auch nicht.
Und das Game suckt so nach dem Motto oder die Gegner cheaten oder was auch immer.
Gerade am Anfang merkt man das richtig, wenn ein neues Game rauskommt und man spielt ein bisschen.
Am Anfang kriegt man erstmal auf den Sack, vor allem wenn man nicht gleich am Anfang direkt mit einschneidet.
Und man merkt so die ersten paar Tage dann, dass es fast instant besser wird, wenn man mal 3-4 Tage gespielt hat.
Und dann geht es natürlich langsam, aber jeder kriegt das halbwegs hin.
Selbst, ich behaupte mal, selbst wenn du irgendwie einen 70-jährigen Opa hättest, der das noch lernen will.
Sogar der würde halbwegs gescheit spielen, wenn er ordentlich Zeit reinsteckt.
Wie gesagt, der macht jetzt da keine 150 zu 2 Quadruple-Nuke-Gameplays oder irgendwelche Facet-CS-Geschichte.
Aber normale Games kann der auch ziemlich gut spielen, wenn er einfach die Zeit reinsteckt.
Und halt dran bleibt und sich da verbessern will. Das kriegt jeder hin.
Herz390, das Aliexpress hat das manchmal, dass IPs gesperrt werden, dass du nicht anmelden kannst oder IP-Ranges gesperrt werden.
Weiß was ich, das ist wahrscheinlich denen ihre DDoS-Detection oder so.
Ja, genau, guck dir Speedrunner an, die irgendwie 15.000 Stunden Mario 64 spielen oder sowas.
Das ist halt auch absolut nicht mit dem 0815 Noob zu vergleichen, der das schon 2-3 Mal...
Also ich spreche mal von Noob, wenn das eine 3-4 Mal casual durchgespielt hat.
Ich sage jetzt nicht einer, der es zum ersten Mal anschaltet, das ist halt ein riesen Unterschied.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen über andere, über fremde Hardware lästern wieder.
Okay, okay, wir müssen uns das Intro mal anhören. Oh, der guckt aber fies.
Jetzt habe ich Angst das Video weiter laufen zu lassen.
Der guckt so aggressiv hier. Was ist da los?
Wahrscheinlich ist es einfach noch blöd, Pause gemacht.
Kennst du Senioren, die zocken?
Den Channel, das habe ich schon mal gesehen, aber nicht, dass ich da öfters gucken würde.
Also unter 1.000 Euro ist eigentlich kein Problem, gerade wenn man bereit ist, auch gebrauchte Hardware auf eBay zu kaufen.
Wenn man sich gebrauchte Hardware auf eBay kauft, das geht sogar.
Das Problem an gebrauchter Hardware ist einfach die Lautstärke und der Stromverbrauch oftmals.
Aber man kann sich bestimmt einen ollen DL380 oder irgendwie sowas auf eBay kaufen.
Das Ding ist immer noch okay.
Was ist da drin? Was ist das für einer?
Guck mal, zweimal nix, 8 Kerne, 8 Kerne, das ist preisleistungsmäßig, ist das top.
Kannst du dich nicht beschweren, kriegst du für 130 Euro ein Superserver-System, ist er laut und braucht Strom.
Also der Preis ist nicht so die Challenge, der Stromverbrauch und vor allem die Lautstärke ist das Problem, je nachdem wo man das hinstellen will.
Alter, was ist das für ein Intro?
Da denke ich immer, das ist ein China-Hersteller von SSDs und USB-Sticks.
Ich hab noch nie was gekauft von denen, aber bei AliExpress gibt es immer Lexa-Sticks und SD-Karten und sowas.
Ist das ein China-Hersteller oder gibt es da einfach nur viel bei AliExpress?
Nee, ist kein China-Hersteller.
Ist das das Gehäuse, das ich auch habe?
Sieht klein aus.
Nee, ist es nicht.
Gut, soll ich sagen, überall, das ist auf jeden Fall kein fertiger.
Das ist irgendwas selbst gebaut, das siehst du schon, allein schon, wie das Ganze aufgebaut ist.
Das ist glaube ich, nee, nee, das ist nichts fertiges.
Das sieht übrigens oldschool aus.
Was genau möchte er uns jetzt eigentlich mitteilen mit diesem Video?
Hä?
Ach, der zeigt uns jetzt irgendwelche RZ-Geschichten oder so.
Das Case sieht fast genauso kacke aus, wie das 2AE-Case, was ich hier neben mir liegen hab.
Gut, dass man, also da muss man doch jetzt kein extra Video für, da braucht man doch kein extra Video.
Also jeder, der normalen Rechner zusammenbauen kann, der kann auch in so ein Gehäuse sein Kram einbauen.
Und warum nicht, das macht doch gar keinen Unterschied.
So, kommt in seinen Dreck rein und gut ist.
Wie sie alle eine Konsole haben.
Dreck sieht aber ziemlich ordentlich aus, nice.
Ok, nee, das ist langweilig, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ok, diese Dinger, diese Dinger sind ja immer cringe.
Eine Konsole, nein.
Also im Rack nicht, nee.
Was ich hab, ich hab mehrere Möglichkeiten, mich da anzustöpseln.
Das einfachste ist, die Capture-Card anzuschließen.
Oder ein Rechner, mit so einem langen HDMI-Kabel ist das kein Problem.
Das nächste ist, ich hab so einen KVM-Switch.
So was hier in der Richtung, aber was viel billigeres.
Also ich hab irgendwas für 20€ mal bei Ebay gekauft.
So einen, gibt's teilweise übelst billig, solche Dinger.
Du schließt es an, schließt es hier am Netzwerk an und kannst dann im Browser auf jeden beliebigen Rechner zugreifen, der dran angeschlossen ist.
Aber das ist zu teuer, dann würd ich irgendwo kaufen, 20-30€, muss irgendwie hauptsächlich billig.
Bei den alten Dingern braucht man leider noch Java installiert, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, oder ausbauen über den Rechner stellen.
Naas fertig kaufen oder was eigenes basteln.
Jetzt kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Wenn du möglichst wenig Probleme haben willst, bzw. möglichst wenig machen willst und einfach was out of the box haben willst, dann kannst du ja fertig kaufen.
Die sind nicht schlecht, also man kann sich so ein Synology-Ding, kann man sich ohne Probleme kaufen.
Also ich muss sagen, die Software da drauf hat mich echt überzeugt.
Sau viele Funktionen, ziemlich easy zu bedienen.
Aber ansonsten, wenn du es halt vielleicht ein bisschen leistungsfähiger, ein bisschen günstiger,
individueller oder eben ein eigenes Linux drauf laufen lassen willst, dann kannst du ja auch was eigenes bauen.
Das ist halt die Frage, was man macht.
Es ist wie bei allem, man muss sich überlegen, was man machen will.
Bei Computer 1993.
Oh, excellent.
Aha, alles klar.
So, okay.
Diese Videos sind meistens übelst cringe, weil sie bestehen zum größten Teil daraus, wie sie zeigen, dass die Leute frühstücken,
Kaffee trinken, Mittag essen, Pong spielen oder Switch spielen oder sonst was.
Diese ganzen A Day in the Life, die bestehen meistens aus irgendwelchen cringe Sachen, die mit der Realität nichts zu tun haben.
Mal gucken, ob das realistischer ist.
Weil ich meine, wenn es die Work from Home Edition ist, da kann der Typ jetzt nicht erstmal in den Pong Raum gehen und Pong spielen oder so komisches Zeug.
Erinnert ihr euch daran, wir haben mal so ein Video geguckt.
Das war von irgendeinem deutschen Startup-Ding in Frankfurt.
Und die haben dort auch Dinge erzählt, so nach dem Motto, kostenlose Snacks und guckt mal hier, kostenlosen Kaffee.
Da haben wir eine kostenlose Spielzimmer, da haben wir kostenlose Sportangebote, blablabla.
Und das sah so aus, als würden die Typen von einem 8-Stunden-Tag, also die machen erst mal keinen 8-Stunden-Tag.
Die machen normalerweise 12-Stunden-Tage, weil Startup und geil und so und geht.
Und von diesen 12-Stunden-Tagen sind die irgendwie 2 Stunden am Programmieren und 2 Stunden was machen.
Den Rest sind sie am Essen, spielen oder chillen auf dem Sofa.
So sehen immer diese Werbe-Filmchen da aus. Mal gucken, ob das ein bisschen realistischer ist.
Erst mal Ultra-High-Res-Cover. Von wann ist denn das Video? Ja, okay, ist neu.
Okay, High-Res-Cover, aber High-Res-Image.
Moment, der könnte nicht leiser reden, oder?
Und die können wieder nicht Sound und Sprache richtig abmischen. Exzellent.
Hey, Moment, ist das? Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist ein Video von einem Programmierer, der tatsächlich programmiert?
Was ist denn da los? Das ist ja realistisch.
Und der hat Monitore hochkantgestellt, dass man was sieht? Das ist ja auch realistisch. Das kann ja nicht sein.
Ich hoffe mal, der hat eine ordentliche Maus und Tastatur hier nebendran liegen, weil niemand kann auf Dauer...
Okay, ich nicht. Ich bezweifle nicht, dass es Leute gibt, die das können.
Aber ich könnte nicht den ganzen Tag an einem Laptop, Tastatur und Laptop-Maus arbeiten.
Am schlimmsten ist die Maus. Die Maus ist eigentlich das Problem.
Also Tastatur kriege ich noch meinetwegen hin, bin ich nicht scharf drauf, aber...
Touchpad ist für'n Arsch.
Aber er hat ne Maus, sonst würde er ja hier mit der Hand rumfuddeln.
Guck mal, die benutzen GitHub-Issues hier.
Das heißt, Google benutzt offiziell ein Microsoft-Produkt jetzt.
Als Programmierer braucht man doch meistens keine Maus, klar.
Nachdem du 70% des Tages damit verbringst, in Google irgendwas zu suchen, brauchst du auch ne Maus, weil Browser ohne Maus bedienen ist kacke.
Oh, jetzt wird Chris geflamed. Im offiziellen Video. Chris kriegt hier erst mal dick die Abmahnung geschickt jetzt.
Oh, 5000 Zeilen pro Tag.
Das ist ja ein bisschen...
Das ist ein bisschen...
Oh, 5000 Zeilen... da hast du ein bisschen was zu tun bis du alles angeguckt hast.
Das sind irgendwie Jason-Config, oder? Kann man mal hinzufügen.
Der soll sich mal nicht so anstellen.
Moment, die wollen wirklich erzählen, dass ein Software Engineer programmiert?
Was ist denn da los?
Das ist ja gar kein typisches Werbevideo.
Also normalerweise, in den meisten anderen Videos hier, a day in a life of, wäre er jetzt
schon dreimal essen gegangen, zweimal Switch spielen, fünfmal Smalltalk in der Cafeteria
und hätte gerade mal sein Rechner gestartet.
Oh, Anzeige ist raus.
17 Scrum Meetings gemacht, Teamrunde, alles.
Erstmal, das ist sogar realistisch.
Das erste was du machst ist, erstmal googeln, weil du keine Ahnung hast.
Das ist auch realistisch.
Erstmal Aplänen, Pull-Quest Closed.
Es ist ja, okay, was ich auch geil finde ist, und das ist gar nicht unrealistisch, dass
es gar nicht um inhaltliche Änderungen geht, sondern so Formfehler.
Der Copyright-Header ist falsch, die Returns-Doc ist verkehrt und sowas.
Das hat alles mit dem eigentlichen Code und der Logik nichts zu tun.
Ich dachte, weil man richtig professionell ist, macht man hier jetzt einen Emoji dahinter,
und dann machst du doch keinen Ausruf und dann musst du hier Sinking Emoji machen,
sonst ist das gar nicht hip genug.
What?
Was zum… stopft der da irgendwelche Tauben aus, oder was da?
Kann man mal nebenbei machen, während man wartet bis das ganze kompiliert ist, erstmal
NPM Update und dann erst mal so eine Gans ausstopfen.
Da, das nicht noch gehalten wird.
Jetzt sind wir verbunden, aber es gibt keine Indikationen, dass wir verbunden sind, also wenn ich...
Was soll das denn?
...einen Befehl ausführen, passiert nichts.
Also, was wir wollen, ist, uns zu bewerben, dass, hey, da ist ein Problem.
Einer der Geheimnisse, um eine große Kodebase zu handeln, ist, einen großen Monitor zu haben.
Oder zwei Big Monitors.
Ich mag das übrigens nicht, ich hab das ausprobiert, mal, auch mit hochkantem Bildschirm, das ist Geschmackssache.
Also mir hat's nicht gefallen.
Da musst du auch ein bisschen permanent so am Kopfhoch und runter bewegen, ich mag...
Nee, hat mir nicht gefallen.
Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht, benutzt jemand hochkantem Bildschirme?
Es klingt erst mal nice.
Ich mein, gerade bei langen Files, vor allem wenn die Leute irgendeinen C++ Crap lesen müssen,
der ist ja oftmals 18.000 Zeilen lang, dann vielleicht, aber mir gefällt's nicht.
Was, nur einen? Okay.
Nee, ich mag das gar nicht.
Ich hab hier zwei Monitore neben mir, beide ganz normalen Wide-Screen auf der Arbeit,
und einen großen Wide-Screen und einen Notput-Monitor.
Hochkant-curved, das wär mal was.
Es geht dann bis zur Decke.
Vier zu drei finde ich sogar ziemlich gut dafür.
Da hat man ein bisschen mehr Platz und es ist nicht so ein riesen Wand, die man vor sich hat.
Interviews.
Das ist ja wirklich mal ein realistisches Video.
Eins war schon mal nicht realistisch, in Wirklichkeit wären die Kinder schon drei Mal reingekommen
und hätten wahrscheinlich genervt, während er gerade am Programmieren ist.
So überhaupt nicht gestellt.
Moment.
Wenn der Kinder hat, dann hat er auch eine Frau.
Kann ja gar nicht sein.
Wollen wir nicht ernsthaft erzählen, das Programmieren, das glaube ich nicht.
Das muss fake sein.
Exposed.
Das war ein echt realistisches Video.
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Das ist ein Tag, wo ich mir durchaus vorstellen könnte, dass der genauso läuft.
Vor allem, was halt wirklich realistisch war, was der halt auch gemacht hat.
Nicht so dieses übliche, wir machen 15 Scrums, gehen 13 mal essen und chillen auf dem Sofa
und programmieren 15 Minuten.
Das hatte durchaus was realistisches.
Kingwall, naja, also laut diesen ganzen Werbevideos ist das ja nicht so.
Sobald du da so einen hippen Technik-Job hast, machst du den ganzen Tag nichts, außer hip sein.
Du hast ja keine Nerf-Guns im Büro und so.
Das kann ja schon mal gar nicht sein.
Ich finde diese ganzen Videos, wo sie erzählen wollen, wie super dynamisch und agil und geil.
Die sind so unrealistisch cringe immer.
Weil das Einzige, wozu das führt, ist so der Druck, dass man mehr macht, als man sollte.
Stellt euch mal vor, irgendeine Firma hat wirklich so einen Raum mit PlayStation und Switch und so.
Und du setzt dich da mittags mal eine halbe Stunde hin und spielst und dein Chef läuft durch.
Da hast du doch instant das Gefühl, du musst jetzt gleich noch mal eine Stunde länger arbeiten.
Weil du hast ja mittags da gesessen und gespielt.
Entweder ist das was, was einfach nur zur Show da ist und keiner benutzt es.
Oder aber es dient dazu, die Leute dazu zu bringen, mehr zu machen, als eigentlich gedacht ist.
Das ist glaube ich die hauptsächliche Sache.
Das ist auch diese Sache mit, wir arbeiten dort, wir leben dort, wir schlafen dort.
Nach dem Motto, dass man 24-7 mehr oder weniger für die Firma da ist.
Kennst du den Snackraum neben Garmens Büro?
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Also ich will nicht ausschließen, Chat, dass es Leben gibt, wo das normal ist und auch benutzt wird.
Und keiner irgendwie ein schlechtes Gewissen gemacht bekommt.
So sollte es ja dann eigentlich auch sein.
Aber ich glaube bei den meisten ist das nicht so.
Dort wo ich arbeite ist eh kein Maßstab, weil wir sind halt super Stocks Business Bank.
Da ist nichts lustig.
Und wenn was lustig ist, gibt es irgendeiner, der sich darüber aufregt, dass es lustig ist.
Das ist eh geil.
Wir haben teilweise echt so viele Leute mit Stock im Arsch.
Das ist teilweise auch schon wieder lustig.
Wir hatten mal einen, ein Kollege von mir war am Wochenende da und hatte nur kurze Hose an.
Es gibt bei uns keine Kleideordnung oder irgendwas.
Es war mitten im Sommer Wochenende, also einer der beim Support arbeitet bei uns.
Sie sind ja auch am Wochenende da, also sprich die sind 24-7 da, Support Leute.
Also ihr Telefon-Support und Störungsmanagement und Monitoring überwachen sind die 24-7 da.
Und da war irgendwann, fragt mich nicht, sonntags, mittags im Sommer da.
Und hatte halt eine kurze Hose an.
Also aus meiner Sicht absolut in Ordnung und vollkommen verständlich.
Der raucht halt, ist runtergegangen, ist runtergegangen, hat sich in Innenhof gestellt, hat einige geraucht.
So und wie der Zufall will, war dann auch, vielleicht war es auch Samstag, weil Sonntag ist keine Schulung,
war auch irgendeine Schulung für Außendienstleute.
Und da stand halt im Hof, irgendwie fragt mich nicht, 35 Anzugs-Außendienstleute.
Und er stand da halt auch und hat geraucht und mit der kurzen Hose.
Und ihr werdet sich glauben, es hat keinen Tag gedauert, da hat sich irgendein Typ bei seinem Chef beschwert,
wie das sein kann, dass da so ein Dude mit kurzer Hose rumläuft.
Es ist natürlich nichts passiert.
Es gibt keine, also ich finde es allein schon lächerlich, dass man sich da überhaupt drüber aufregt.
Also das ist ja, du musst erstmal fragen, wie fettig musst du im Kopf sein, dass du den jetzt irgendwie anschwärzen willst
und dir nichts besseres einfällt, als wenn du kurze Hose angehabt hättest.
Aber die haben sich dann wirklich angepisst gefühlt, dass einer da unten steht mit kurzer Hose.
Und es ist nichts passiert.
Wie gesagt, es gibt keine Kleiderordnung oder sonst was.
Also es gibt auch keine, es gibt da keine Handhabe, irgendwas zu machen oder so.
Es ist auch bescheuert und will auch keiner.
Aber allein schon da sieht man mal, wie manche Anzugs-Stonks-Menschen drauf sind.
Das ist für die so, wie wenn ihr irgendwie irgendwelche Aliens sehen würdet,
würde der denken, hör dir, das ist aber nicht normal.
Und der denkt so, das ist ja nicht normal, wie sowas geht.
Ey, gibt's auch mehr so Dinger.
Aber wie gesagt, also bei uns ist ja auch die Sache, bei uns ist nichts lustig.
Und wenn was lustig ist, dann wird es schlecht geredet, weil es so lustig ist.
Das ist halt sehr Oldschool-Bank-mäßig bei uns.
Aber sie geben sich gerade Mühe.
Sie wollen ein bisschen hipper werden.
Das merkt man.
Also in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren versuchen sie ein bisschen mehr mit so agilen Sachen um sich zu werfen.
Dass wir jetzt ja super agil sind, ohne dass was passiert.
Wir erzählen das einfach nur.
Dann machen wir manchmal solche Verbesserungsvorschläge, Workshops und sowas,
wo wir versuchen jetzt hip zu sein.
Klappt nicht so ganz, klappt nicht.
Bist du bei der EZB?
Nee, klappt nicht so gut.
Oder vielleicht, ich sag nicht, wo ich bin.
Die versuchen dann so ein bisschen hip zu sein.
Spezialist sagt, bei mir haben sich die Chefs beschwert, dass ich zu wenig lächel auf der Arbeit.
Du stehst acht Stunden an der Maschine.
Okay, wenn das relevant ist für die.
Was auch witzig war, ich glaube aber, das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt.
Wo man auch sieht, dass die ein bisschen hipper werden wollen.
Es wurde ein Werbefilm gedreht bei uns.
Also ein Werbefilm für den Außendienst über unsere Support-Abteile.
Da haben wir einen Werbefilm gedreht.
Und ich sitze ja dort auch in dem Büro.
Ich gehöre da zwar offiziell nicht dazu, aber ich sitze da auch in dem Büro.
Und die haben einen Werbefilm gedreht, um beim Außendienst einen besseren Win zu machen für die Support-Abteile.
Frag mich nicht, wozu.
Zumindest haben sie dazu ein eigenes Kamerateam geholt.
Und dann sind die in das Büro gegangen.
Und ihr könnt euch ja vorstellen, wie das Support-Team aussieht.
Da sitzen insgesamt 10-15 Leute.
Das sind alles mittelalte weiße Männer.
So wie halt so eine normale 0815-Support-Abteilung aussieht.
Also von 25 bis 65 und halt alles Männer.
0815, so wie es halt in so einer IT-Support-Abteilung aussieht.
So und dann ist diesem Kamerateam und ich weiß nicht, ob man das Regisseur nennen kann, dem Aufnahmemann dann aufgefallen.
Okay, das ist aber aktuell nicht so angesagt.
Und da haben sie wirklich, sind sie durchs Haus und haben sich Leute gesucht, die man da hinsetzen könnte.
So und am Ende, anstatt dass da irgendwie drei Leute, wie es realistisch wäre, rumgesessen haben.
Also drei mittelalte weiße Männer rumgesessen haben.
Wohl noch, vielleicht sogar in kurzer Hose.
Haben sie dann am Ende gehabt.
Eine mit Kopftuch.
Die DBA-Frau.
Dann haben sie von der Qualitätssicherung noch eine geholt.
Einen schwarzen, zwei schwarze vom Netzwerk haben sie noch geholt.
Da saßen dann am Ende sieben Leute rum.
Die drei durchschnittsweiße Männer, die halt realistisch normal dort im Support arbeiten.
Zwei schwarze Männer und Frau mit Kopftuch, bisschen ältere Frau und DBA-Frau.
Also das sah so richtig wie aus dem Bilderbuch.
Man hat es jetzt quasi divers gemacht, komplett abseits jeglicher Realität.
Aber es hat sich halt für Werbezwecke besser geeignet.
Hat mit der Realität absolut nichts zu tun gehabt.
Nein, überhaupt nicht gestaget, überhaupt nichts gestaget.
Aber der Film ist echt nicht schlecht.
Also man muss sagen, die haben da wirklich jemand angeheuert, der solche Werbe-Filmchen machen kann.
Der Film ist wirklich gut geworden.
Also für das, was er sein soll.
Tja.
Ghost Rider sagt, meine Kollegen haben ihre Boni nicht bekommen, weil die wohl unfreundlich sein soll.
Was ist denn das für eine komische, also das erste sehr subjektive Sache.
Und auf welchen Gründen gibt es Boni und wie nicht.
Ist der Film online?
Gute Frage.
Ich glaube nicht.
Das war so ein internes Werbe-Filmchen für unseren Außendienst, wie geil wir sind.
Oder besser gesagt, wie geil die Support-Abteilung ist.
Ich bin nicht drauf zu sehen.
Mein Schreibtisch, mein unaufgeräumter Schreibtisch ist teilweise kurz zu sehen.
Im Video.
Ich war in dem Tag Gannert dort an dem Schreibtisch.
Ein unaufgeräumter Schreibtisch, der ist zu sehen.
Sneaky Boy sagt, eine Freundin hat erzählen, dass für die Werbe-Fotos für Frauen in der IT einfach die Praktikantin aus der Verwaltung geschnappt worden ist, die sie vor einen Server-Rack gestellt haben.
Ja, die Werbung, wann hatte Werbung schon mal was mit der Realität zu tun?
Jetzt hier Ghost Rider, weil Ghost Rider geschrieben hat, die Leute kriegen keine Boni, weil sie unfreundlich sind.
Bei uns haben sie sich dieses Jahr auch wieder was Gutes ausgedacht.
Also bei uns gibt es eigentlich so gut wie immer Boni.
Es ist glaube ich noch kein Jahr passiert, wo es nicht zumindest diesen normalen Bonus gab.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es den trotz Corona gibt.
Aber was bei uns lustig ist, die feiern sich jedes Jahr übelst ab.
So nach dem Motto, wieder das erfolgreichste Jahr und wieder das erfolgreichste Jahr.
Wir haben ja auch, wir verleihen uns ja auch immer selber Preise.
Also entweder gehört uns das oder wir sitzen dort in der Jury mit drin oder wir verleihen uns schlicht und ergreifend einfach einen ausgedachten Preis selbst.
Aber das ist gang und gäbe, wenn ihr da mal rumguckt.
Das macht da eigentlich jeder.
Und da feiern sie sich wieder, dass man wieder irgendwas gewonnen hat und so.
Aber ich weiß nicht wer von euch, also gerade so im Start-up Bereich und so im Bankenversicherungsgewerbe.
Ich glaube, diese zwei, da kann man nicht Branchen nennen, diese zwei Sachen, die haben das Selbstfeiern perfektioniert.
Und wir feiern uns auch gerne selbst.
Zumindest feiern die sich halt wie gesagt regelmäßig.
Am geilsten ist immer Sommerfest und Weihnachtsfeiern, wo ich auch nicht mehr hingehe.
Da wird sich immer übertrieben selbst gefeiert.
Sogar Betriebsversammlung ist übertriebenes Selbstfeiern.
Und was ja eigentlich was komplett anderes ist, komplettes Selbstfeiern.
Zumindest die sind halt sich komplett am Selbstfeiern durchgängig.
Und dann sind ja, weil wir ja so geil sind, kommen die Leute manchmal auf die Idee zu sagen,
wenn es doch so gut läuft und wir uns so feiern, dann könnt ihr uns doch auch mehr Geld geben.
Klingt ja auch erstmal logisch, ne?
Also wenn man sich gar so krass selbst feiert, dann könnte man die Leute auf die Idee bringen,
wenn es ja so geil ist und so gut läuft, dass sie nach mehr Geld fragen.
So und dann muss man sich immer was einfallen lassen, was man den Leuten erzählt, warum sie nicht mehr Geld kriegen können.
Und dieses Jahr ist natürlich Corona, geht nicht.
Dieses Jahr ist Corona.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen um die Ecke, weil sie können nicht einfach sagen Corona,
weil sie auf der anderen Seite ja sagen, dieses Jahr ist auch wieder super erfolgreich und super geil.
Also sprich, wie verkauft man das jetzt am besten, dass man den Leuten wegen Corona nicht mehr Geld geben will,
aber man doch die geilste Sau überhaupt ist.
Das ist schwierig.
Und es ging jetzt dieses Jahr folgendermaßen.
Man hat offiziell nicht gesagt, dass es wegen Corona ist.
Man hat offiziell gar nichts gesagt.
Sprich, man hat einfach jedem sagen lassen, hier, wie sieht es aus, mehr Geld.
Und die Chefs haben dann gesagt, ja, okay, geben wir weiter, geben wir weiter.
Und irgendwann ist dann halt mal so ein Ding, wo das entschieden wird.
Und die haben das über zwei Management-Ebenen weitergeben lassen,
bis dann irgendwann der Typ, der Oberabteilungsmann, der das entscheidet,
quasi vollkommen empört gesagt haben muss, so nach dem Motto, wie man das eigentlich wagen kann,
dass so viele Leute, also so nach dem Motto, wie unfeinfühlig man sein kann,
hat er seinen Abteilungsleiter angeschossen, dass man überhaupt wagt, in Corona-Zeiten nach mehr Geld zu fragen.
Also sie haben das nicht offiziell gesagt, weil dann würde man ja feststellen,
man ist doch nicht der geilste Laden überhaupt.
Die haben es eher so indirekt gemacht.
Und dann die Leute, die für ihre Mitarbeiter gefragt haben, angeschossen,
warum man dann, wie man dann überhaupt fragen kann in der aktuellen Zeit.
Was natürlich unterm Strich nichts ändert, dass die Leute mehr Kohle haben wollen.
Da muss ich echt sagen, da bin ich wirklich begeistert gewesen von meinem Chef vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Ich kümmere mich ja null um solche Strongs-Finanzgeschichten.
Also wahrscheinlich hätte ich die letzten Jahre einfach mal mehr nerven müssen,
da würde ich sogar noch ein bisschen mehr kriegen.
Ich habe vor zwei Jahren mal wieder meinem Chef gesagt, hier, so langsam aber sicher wird mal wieder Zeit,
ich brauche mal mehr Geld.
Und außer das zu sagen, ich musste nichts machen, da kam der kurz vor Weihnachten,
zu mir und hat gemeint, ja, er war jetzt oben und hat das erzählt und gibt jetzt mehr Geld.
Hab ich gerade, okay.
Alles gut, nice.
Aber dieses Jahr hätte das nicht funktioniert.
Ja, das war wirklich geil.
Aber die Begründung ist natürlich total bescheuert wegen Corona.
Also du kannst nicht auf der einen Seite erwarten, dass die Leute immer mehr, immer flexibler und
ja, einseitig mehr Zeug leisten und dann sagen, es gibt nichts.
Das ist natürlich unverhältnismäßig.
Aber dieses Jahr habe ich, also ich habe dieses Jahr gar nicht gefragt,
bei mir war er letztes Jahr erst und ich muss auch sagen,
ich finde es dieses Jahr äußerst angenehm, auch hauptsächlich dank Corona.
Wir können ziemlich viel Homeoffice machen, ich spare mir hin und zurückfahren,
das ist eigentlich der größte Faktor.
Ich kann quasi die Stunden, die zwei Stunden, die zweieinhalb Stunden, wo ich unterwegs bin,
kann ich, naja gut, sagen wir mal, zwei Stunden, das sind die zweieinhalb Stunden.
Die zwei Stunden, wo ich unterwegs bin, kann ich jetzt einfach länger pennen.
Also es macht so viel aus, ob man 5.45 Uhr aufsteht oder 7.45 Uhr.
Das ist einfach weltenunterschied, ja.
Mein T-Kanne geht nicht auf.
Das macht einfach einen riesen Unterschied.
Also ich bin dieses Jahr wirklich echt zufrieden.
Den normalen Bonus Ende des Jahres gehe ich davon aus, wird es eh geben.
Ich habe wieder bei einigen Dingern freiwillig mitgemacht,
kann sein, dass ich sogar noch, also wäre auf jeden Fall cool, wenn es was gibt,
wenn es wieder so ein extra Ding gebe, was es manchmal gibt,
bei den Leuten, die, ich weiß nicht nach was das entschieden wird,
die besonderen Einsatz gezeigt haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das entschieden wird.
Mal gucken.
Den dabei habe ich gar nicht so viel gemacht,
aber wahrscheinlich, ich hoffe mal, bei den richtigen Sachen.
Na ja, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was das entschieden wird.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das entschieden wird.
Na ja, also jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Wir waren teilweise, 11 oder 12 Tage am Stück ohne Tag frei dazwischen
haben wir gearbeitet, als die Kacke am Dampfen war bei uns,
wo so viel Zeug kaputt war.
Also das kann man schon als besonderen Einsatz werden.
Da haben sie sich ja auch selbst übertroffen,
was die Zeiterfassung anging.
Also eine Sache, ich finde es bei uns eigentlich ganz gut,
aber eine Sache, die mir wirklich auf den Keks geht,
ist die Personalabteilung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch so aussieht,
aber unsere Personalabteilung, die haben sich, glaube ich,
von irgendwelchen, die haben sich vom Finanzamt oder so
irgendwelche Vordrucke geholt, wie man Briefe schreibt.
Die schreiben, oder was heißt Briefe oder Mails oder Nachrichten,
die schreiben das nicht normal.
Die schreiben das so gottgegeben, so was weiß ich,
Gott spricht zu euch, so irgendwie, oder so.
Kann man schwer beschreiben, zumindest.
Wie gesagt, wir haben ja 10, 11, 12 Tage am Stück gearbeitet,
weil so viel kaputt war bei uns.
Und da kam jetzt natürlich die Frage auf,
okay, wie rechnet man das Ganze ab?
Weil die Zeiterfassung ging ja nicht.
Die Zeiterfassung war ja auch kaputt.
Das ist ein Windows-System, und das war ein Windows-System,
was betroffen war, Zeiterfassung ging nicht.
Das heißt, du musstest jetzt nachträglich
in dieser Zeiterfassung Software, Software oder Hardware kaputt,
ja, Windows, Windows kaputt.
Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner, Zeug und so.
Die Linerung war übrigens kein Problem, hat alles funktioniert.
So, und dann war die erste Frage,
okay, wie sollen wir das denn abrechnen?
Dann haben wir alles gemacht.
Ich hab da irgendwie keine Ahnung, drei Wochen gebraucht,
bis das richtig eingetragen war,
weil es ist ultra wirr gewesen, wie du das eintragen musst, so.
Und dann hatten wir das alles eingetragen,
mein Chef hat alles genehmigt, wunderbar.
Und da hat letzte Woche sogar hier am, es kam ne Mail,
am 6. von der Personalabteilung an den Chef von meinem Chef kam ne Mail,
dass wir das jetzt doch alles komplett anders abrechnen müssen
und die Leute dort die falschen Buchungs-IDs oder so dran geschrieben haben.
Dass man sich überhaupt um so was kümmern muss,
ist schon mal total hängen geblieben.
So, und dann hat der die Mail weitergeleitet an meinen Chef.
So, und dann hab ich hier am 7. morgens hab ich die Mail bekommen.
Ey, und wie diese Mail geschrieben war, das war unter aller Sau.
Das war ne Mail von der Personalabteilung,
da stand quasi sinngemäß drinne.
Man muss die ganze Zeiterfassung neu machen, so sieht das aus.
Und es muss erledigt sein bis 7.10.17 Uhr,
weil es sonst nicht mehr für die Abrechnung berücksichtigt werden kann.
Also mal unterm Strich, was die damit gesagt haben,
was eigentlich unter aller Sau ist und wo ich mich auch übelst nur aufgeregt hab.
Was die damit gesagt haben ist, wir haben die Leute 11 Tage am Stück arbeiten lassen,
haben uns am 6. dazu entschieden, dass die noch mal alles ändern müssen.
Und die haben jetzt einen halben Tag für Zeit das zu machen.
Und wenn sie es nicht machen, dann wird es nicht mehr für die aktuelle Abrechnung berücksichtigt.
Also im Prinzip unterm Strich haben die gesagt,
wenn ich es nicht mach, gibt es dafür kein Geld erst mal.
Was, also so sinngemäß stand das da.
Was halt komplett, also was glaube ich nur rechtlich problematisch ist, das zu machen.
Und auch so weiß ich nicht, was im Kopf der Leute vorgeht.
Zumindest worauf das jetzt rausgelaufen ist, ist jetzt kein Witz,
weil so wie die das jetzt erfasst haben wollten, war ultra kompliziert,
noch komplizierter als das letzte Mal.
Und wir haben ohne Scheiß zweieinhalb Stunden zusammen im Teams gesessen,
mit dem Kollege zusammen, zweieinhalb Stunden haben wir im Teams gesessen
und haben die Zeiterfassung gemacht.
Also wir haben quasi fast einen Tag, wenn du die Leute,
wenn du uns, wenn du uns zwei zusammen nimmst,
haben wir fast einen Tag gebraucht, an Stunden um die Zeiterfassung zu machen.
Das war ex, ey, es war ultra, natürlich Arbeitszeit, was sonst?
Es war ultra kompliziert.
Ursprünglich dachte ich mir, okay, Max, du machst dir einfach.
Du trägst ein in die Zeiterfassung, sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal,
beispielsweise gearbeitet, Sonntag von 10 bis 22 Uhr.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal irgendwas, ja.
Gut, das trägst du ein.
Und dann trägst du in die Zeiterfassung ein 0 bis 24 Uhr Bereitschaft,
weil ich hatte die ganze Zeit das Handy dabei.
Das war ja das erste Problem schon.
Das kann unsere Zeiterfassungssoftware nicht.
Die kapiert nicht, wenn ich 0 bis 24 Uhr Bereitschaft eintrage
und 0 bis 18 Uhr gearbeitet habe.
Dann kann die das nicht merchen oder diffen.
Die kriegt das nicht gebacken.
Das heißt, du musst schon mal eintragen,
0 Uhr bis 10 Uhr Bereitschaft, 10 Uhr bis 18 Uhr, oder sagen wir mal,
0 Uhr bis 16 Uhr Bereitschaft, 16 Uhr bis 23 Uhr Arbeiten
und dann 23 bis 0 Uhr wieder Bereitschaft.
So, das ist schon abfuck, hoch 10.
Damit ist die Sache aber noch nicht erledigt.
Das wäre viel zu einfach,
wenn das alles schon gewesen wäre, was man machen muss.
Dann musst du gucken, dass es natürlich keine Überschneidung gibt.
Aber es dürfen auch keine Minuten dazwischen frei sein.
Also ich darf nicht etwa Bereitschaft bis 13 Uhr 59 buchen ab 14 Uhr anfangen.
Dann kapiert du das Ganze auch wieder nicht.
Dazu kommt, dass man die richtigen, hinten in so einem Dropdown,
dass man die richtigen IDs auswählen muss.
Nämlich nicht einfach nur Bereitschaft,
sondern Notfallbereitschaft muss man auswählen.
Was das eine hat an ID 115 und das andere 116.
Und natürlich muss man 116 nehmen und nicht 115. Ist ja auch klar.
So, als wir das gemacht haben, haben wir erfahren,
es ist immer noch falsch,
weil wir haben die Anfahrtswege nicht richtig abgerechnet.
Die Anfahrtswege mussten jetzt noch genau dazwischen,
sodass man buchen musste 0 bis 16 Uhr, Bereitschaft 113.
Dann musste man buchen 16 bis 17 Uhr,
irgendwie Notfallbereitschaft Anfahrt,
dann Bereitschaftseinsatz vor Ort und dann Heimfahrt
und dann wieder Bereitschaft.
Und dann haben wir noch vergessen, den Häkchen zu machen,
dass wir außer den Rahmenarbeitszeiten gearbeitet haben.
Das war so kompliziert.
Wie gesagt, wir haben zu zweit für die paar Tage,
wir haben zweieinhalb Stunden zu zweit im Teams gesessen
und haben Zeiterfassung gemacht,
weil das so übertrieben kompliziert war.
Das ist auch richtig.
Was habt ihr für eine Kacksoftware? Mega Kacksoftware.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich das erzählen kann,
weil ich nicht weiß, wie viele Leute das verwenden.
Naja.
Okay, das ist nichts für uns.
Das kann ich doch zeigen.
Ich kann doch zeigen, was wir für eine Zeiterfassung haben.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Äh.
Das sieht ja alles so modern aus. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Hier. So ungefähr sieht das aus.
Ungefähr so sieht das aus.
Viel zu modern, viel zu modern.
Unsere Version ist viel älter.
So ungefähr sieht das aus, so sieht das ungefähr aus.
Ja, ja, genau so.
So sieht unsere Zeiterfassung aus, genau so.
Windows 98. Da steht auch unten Copyright. Copyright 1994 bis 2020.
Das ist wirklich absoluter Müll, diese Software.
So ein abkundtief schlechtes Zeiterfassungssystem.
Matt, wie kennst du das?
Ja, es ist eine Zumutung, es ist komplett eine Zumutung.
Ich glaube, Zeiterfassung ist mittlerweile sogar Pflicht, dass man das macht.
Allerdings, man kann Zeiterfassung auch einfach, einfach machen.
Also, man muss es nicht kompliziert machen.
Hast du RC1 ausprobiert, was? RC1 von was?
Von.NET 5? Nee, machen wir aber noch im Stream, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben.
So, mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Questions übersehen habe.
Interface sieht jetzt echt besser aus. Seit wann?
Ich habe letztens vor ein paar Tagen geupdatet und die Settings sahen ein bisschen anders aus, ja.
Aber leider geht das Tray-Icon immer noch nicht richtig.
Sechs Minuten, genau.
Wisst ihr, mittlerweile bin ich bei sowas schmerzlos.
Wenn die sich das überlegen, dass das so sein muss.
Ich rechne auch zweieinhalb Stunden Zeiterfassung ab, das ist kein Problem.
Und wenn sich dann einer beschwert, dann kriegt er halt erzählt, woran das liegt.
Und wenn er sich dann immer noch beschwert, soll er sich nicht bei mir beschweren.
Ich habe mir jetzt ja nicht ausgedacht, zweieinhalb Stunden Zeiterfassung zu machen.
Natürlich, denn es hört sich jetzt so einfach an, natürlich wird sich dann immer noch bei einem beschwert.
So nach dem Motto, so kompliziert kann das doch nicht sein und sowas.
Aber da kecke ich mittlerweile nur noch, wenn ich das höre.
Vieles ist auch, das ist, ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich glaube, viele meinen das gar nicht böse, wenn sie sowas fragen.
Viele verstehen das bloß nicht.
Weil es gibt viele, also viele Tätigkeiten oder viele Sachen sehen einfach aus.
Wenn man sie losgelöst alleine betrachtet.
Wenn du allerdings auf eine Sache achten musst, dann ist es kein Ding, da dauert es zwei Minuten und gut ist.
Wenn du allerdings auf 16 Sachen achten musst, die miteinander zu tun haben,
wo jede für sich allein losgelöst betrachtet, vielleicht nur zwei Minuten dauert.
Aber die Abhängigkeiten zueinander haben und miteinander in Konflikt, dann dauert es halt zwei Stunden anstatt zwei Minuten.
So und ich glaube, das ist vielen, die sich das von außen angucken und selbst sowas nicht machen müssen, nicht klar.
Es ist genauso, wie es bei uns mittlerweile übelst kompliziert ist, wenn du einfach nur Wartungsarbeiten machen möchtest.
Also als ich angefangen habe, oder sag mal so, als ich noch bei diesem Provider gearbeitet habe, war das mit Wartungsarbeiten ziemlich einfach.
Zwar war es kaputt, irgendeiner hat dich angerufen und hat gesagt, oh Max, hier ist irgendwas kaputt, du hast dich drauf eingeloggt,
du hast das hotfixed live am System und dann ging es wieder.
So und das ist natürlich auch nicht unbedingt komplett erweist, als letzter Schluss, aber das war ziemlich easy.
So, mittlerweile ist das natürlich bankstonks mäßig, wie das bei uns geht.
Du kannst nicht einfach Wartungsarbeiten an irgendeinem System machen.
Du musst, keine Ahnung, du musst dich erstmal an 15 verschiedene Leute wenden, die dir alle einen Senf dazu geben.
So, jetzt haben wir die Change-Kalender und Change-Manager.
Wenn du die Change-Manager fragst, die werden dann allerdings sagen, sie haben gar keine Ahnung,
dann gibt es unterschiedliche Sub-Change-Manager, die für unterschiedliche Changes zuständig sind.
Und letztens hatten wir das Problem, dass einer dieser Sub-Change-Manager, also einschließt mal,
der musste, der hat einen Auflösungsvertrag unterschrieben, sagen wir mal so, der ist nicht mehr da.
Und dann habe ich die übergeordneten Change-Koordinatoren gefragt,
welchen Change-Manager ich denn jetzt für diese Art von Wartungsarbeit fragen kann,
weil der alte Change-Manager ist ja nicht mehr da.
Und ich muss da was machen, weil ansonsten läuft das Zertifikat aus.
Wenn das Zertifikat ausläuft, dann ist die Webseite kaputt.
War keine Webseite, aber so beispielsweise.
Und die Antwort von den oberen Change-Koordinatoren war nur,
Max, da können wir dir leider nichts zu sagen, wir wurden bisher darüber noch nicht informiert.
Und dann frage ich mich, wozu braucht man Change-Manager und Change-Koordinatoren,
wenn ihr eh selbst den ganzen Kram suchen müsst?
Man weiß es nicht, man weiß es nicht, aber kein Problem, dann schreibe ich halt auf,
zwei Stunden Ansprechpartner gesucht, was soll ich denn machen?
Mir bleibt ja wirklich nichts anderes übrig, dann suche ich zwei Stunden Ansprechpartner.
Oder aber das nächste ist, wenn es gar keinen Ansprechpartner gibt und es keiner entscheiden will,
dann wird halt die Webseite kaputt gehen.
So scheiße, so blöd das ist und so einfach man solche Fehler vermeiden könnte.
Wenn diese Verwaltung aufgebaut wurde in dieser Komplexität
und die Leute, die eigentlich dafür da sind, dass es managable bleibt, es nicht schaffen,
kann ich auch nichts machen.
Also ITIL finden sie auch geil, frag mich nicht, nach welchem System bei uns das ge-
was, ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch wurscht.
Ach ja, und dann gibt es noch, dann gibt es doch, das ist auch richtig big brain,
da gibt es noch Emergency Changes.
Allerdings kann man nicht einfach so einen Emergency Change machen,
selbst wenn, selbst wenn Emergency ist,
sondern man muss dann einen Ad-hoc-Change beim Change-Manager machen,
was auch irgendwie die ganze Sache untergräbt,
weil ein Emergency Change bedeutet eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt nicht unmittelbar was mache,
geht noch viel mehr kaputt.
Aber ich habe mir da mittlerweile, ich mache mir da wirklich keine Gedanken mehr drüber,
ich mache das mittlerweile einfach.
Und es sind schon einige Dinge kaputt gegangen und haben nicht funktioniert
und sind sogar ausgefallen durch diese Geschichte.
Gut, aber ein Vorteil hat es, und das meine ich jetzt wirklich ernst,
ein Vorteil hat dieses riesen Verwaltungskoordinationskonstrukt.
Du bist nie an was schuld, selbst wenn du daran schuld bist.
Du kannst das immer irgendwie, also wenn du willst, du kannst das immer auf irgendwas anderes schieben.
Und es kann dir faktisch keiner mehr ans Bein pinkeln.
Also du musst schon sehr offensichtlich Scheiße bauen,
dass du noch da wirklich zur Verantwortung gezogen werden kannst.
Also das einzige Mal, das mir bekannt ist in den letzten fünf Jahren,
wo mal wirklich jemand zur Verantwortung gezogen wurde, der Scheiße gebaut hat, war,
also erstens, es war ein Externer, das kommt ja noch dazu,
und zweitens, der hat mit dem Hersteller von unserem Storage-System telefoniert
und der Hersteller hat ihm gesagt, nein, ihr dürft auf gar keinen Fall die Duplication einschalten,
weil das mit der Firmware-Version, die ihr habt, nicht supportet wird.
So, und daraufhin ist er hingegangen und hat die Duplication eingeschaltet.
So, und dann ist das Storage-System abgekackt.
So, das ist der einzige Fall, den ich kenne, der wirklich zur Verantwortung gezogen wurde
und jetzt auch nicht mehr da ist.
Aber da musst du schon wirklich dich ziemlich pepega anstellen, dass du das hinkriegst.
Ansonsten kannst du dich eigentlich immer irgendwie rausreden.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das aber auch problematisch,
weil wenn du jemanden suchst, der sich für was verantwortlich fühlt,
findest du ihn dann auch nicht richtig.
Wie gesagt, Change-Koordinatoren wären eigentlich dafür da,
dass sie mir sagen können, wer jetzt der passende Change-Manager für diese Wartungsarbeiten ist.
Und die haben sich rausgerechnet mit, wir wurden nicht informiert, können sie mir nicht helfen.
Also das heißt, du stehst dann einfach nur da und denkst dir, keck wait, ja was jetzt?
Ja, Tiger Flashbang, was da gelaufen ist, keine Ahnung.
Mal kurz durchscrollen.
Ich finde es zu neu, kenne ich nicht, wahrscheinlich kacke, weil die alte...
Also ich hatte die K95 und es war die schlechteste Tastatur, die ich je hatte.
Das heißt, ich werde mir im Leben keine K100 kaufen.
Also nicht nur, dass die Tasten übelst rutschig waren,
auf einen wege kann ich mich noch mit abfreunden,
ne, das schlimmste war, dass die Tastatur nach ein paar Wochen doppelte Tastenanschläge hatte.
Und die Corsair Software auch eine absolute Zumutung ist.
Aber doppelte Tastenanschläge nach ein paar Wochen darf nicht sein.
Und an sich die Tastatur wirklich schlecht.
Davon haben wir leider auch einige.
Kurz nochmal hier durchgucken, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Was hältst du eigentlich von einem dualen Studium?
Hast du Erfahrungen mit Leuten, die sowas gemacht haben?
Ja, der Master, also der Karsten, der Master Grabber.
Er ist ein Freund von Friseur und mir.
Das ist der, mit dem ich schon seit Ewigkeiten mal ein Video zum Thema Wirtschaftsinformatikstudium aufnehmen wollte.
Der hat das gemacht und sogar der fand das relativ anstrengend.
Und der Karsten ist jemand, der ist Massive Big Brain.
Also wenn der schon was anstrengend findet, dann ist es wahrscheinlich echt anstrengend.
Der Karsten hat Big'ses Brain von allen hier.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher.
Da bestimmt eine IQ von 155 oder so.
Massive.
Was? Ich habe mal nach einer Gehaltsgehörung gefragt und habe als Antwort bekommen, dass das nicht geht.
Weil es dieser Firma dieses Jahr nicht gut.
Das ist so die Default Antwort.
Keine zwei Minuten gegoogelt und die Aktie der Firma 20%.
Ja, die haben so Standard.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die davon haben.
Meinen die wirklich, also wenn es mit solchen Sachen abgetan wird,
Meinen die wirklich, dass es die Leute irgendwie motiviert?
Ja, mach mal mehr für uns und streng dich mehr an, aber mehr Geld gibt es nicht.
Das ist natürlich furchtbar motivierend.
Ich weiß nicht, worum es geht.
Ach, bei der Zeiterfassung? Nee, das ist einfach nur so bescheid.
Ach nee, hier, bei dem Werbefilm.
Nee, das ist ein ganz normaler Image-Werbefilm.
Das stimmt aber auch.
Man darf sich da nicht so gleich geschlagen geben bei der ersten 0815 Antwort, die kommt.
Das kommt aber ehrlich gesagt, das kommt auch ein bisschen auf den Chef an.
Was man da für einen hat und ob der die Sachen gut verkaufen kann.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Nächstes Jahr frage ich auch wieder.
Hier, da haben sie Pech. Dann soll sie halt dicht machen.
Nee, da wird viel Zeug erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist. Die haben schon ihre Standardantworten.
Lego U-Boot, das haben wir glaube ich schon gesehen.
Ja, ja, das kenne ich schon. Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Wobei, das ist ein neues.
Wenn gar nichts hilft, ist das das Einzige, was übrig bleibt.
Wobei ich es aber auch schon erlebt habe bei uns, dass gerade wenn Azubis fertig geworden sind,
da wollten die die eigentlich übernehmen, aber denen nur ein Apfel und ein Ei bezahlen.
Und als die Azubis dann gesagt haben, nee, das mache ich nicht, da gehe ich woanders hin
und auch wirklich quasi gesagt haben, ich packe jetzt meine Sachen,
dann gab es lustigerweise doch noch ein höheres Angebot und viele sind da geblieben.
Also manchmal ist es wirklich so ein sich gegenseitig ausgespiele,
was ich persönlich ehrlich gesagt bescheuert finde.
Also was ich ehrlich gesagt total bescheuert finde, dass das immer noch so ein rumgetautes hier ist.
Yo, ist dann eigentlich deine Galz? Also die letzte war relativ hoch,
aber ich habe mich auch ewig nicht drum gekümmert und beim nächsten Mal keine Ahnung.
Muss man mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Aber dieses Jahr gebe ich mir das nicht.
Das mache ich nächstes Jahr. Ich mache das nächstes Jahr dann zu dem Termin,
wenn sie wieder verkünden, dass sie die geilsten sind.
Aber ich mache mir da wenig Gedanken drüber, ganz ehrlich.
Es reicht.
Aha, was ist das?
Also ich komme komplett damit aus.
Ich habe ja zwei, ich habe mir extra mehrere Konten gemacht.
Also ich habe das ganz normale Konto, wo mein Gehalt drauf geht von der Arbeit.
Ich habe noch Tagesgeld, den können wir mal nehmen,
weil juckt eh kein mehr, gibt es eh nichts drauf.
Und ich habe ein extra Konto für mein ganzes...
Mir fällt es schwer, Businessgeschichten zu nennen.
Also dort, wo ich YouTube drauf kriege, Twitch drauf kriege
und mir auch, falls ich mal irgendwelche Werbegeschichten mache, das Zeug drauf überweisen lasse.
Das heißt, ich habe da ungefähr einen ganz guten Überblick, was wie wo reinkommt.
Dementsprechend weiß ich auch, über YouTube kommt aktuell nichts rein.
Über YouTube habe ich glaube ich 17 Euro oder so letzten Monat verdient.
Irgendwie so in dem Dreh oder 13, 15, 17, irgendwie so, also nichts.
Ich habe auch nichts gemacht.
Twitch ist tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr, weil hier wird BigBrain subscribtet.
Übrigens, weiß nicht, ob ich das heute schon erwähnt habe,
aber ein Amazon Prime Account kann kostenlos einen Streamer seiner Wahl unterstützen, einmal im Monat.
Hast du eigentlich noch einen Manager?
Ich bin immer noch in diesem YouTube Netzwerk drin.
Ja, mit denen habe ich nichts zu tun.
Zumindest, daran merke ich auch.
Virtu, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das zieht immer wieder.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Virtu, Virtou, Virtu denke ich mal.
Exzellent.
Ich habe die Chat IQ wieder gestiegen.
So, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau.
Und dadurch, dass ich diese zwei unterschiedlichen Eingangskonten habe, weiß ich,
dass ich locker mit der Kohle, die da schon drauf ist und die monatlich reinkommt, auskomme.
Aber locker.
Und ich sehe auf der anderen Seite, was da noch reinkommt.
Ich habe, also, ich habe echt keine Existenzängste oder Probleme mehr.
Ich weiß, dass ich das eine nicht unbedingt machen müsste
und das andere auch nicht unbedingt machen müsste, wenn es mich abfuckt.
Und das ist echt praktisch.
Wenn man weiß, dass man theoretisch ohne könnte, was ich nicht will,
weil ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut da, wo ich bin.
Das macht ja auch schon ab und zu mal Spaß.
Es ist nicht so, dass es alles kacke wäre.
Ich erzähle halt immer nur die lustigen Sachen, wo halt irgendwer es überhaupt nicht geklappt hat.
Aber du investierst auch nicht.
Ja, das ist mein großes Problem, was ich habe,
dass ich mich für so Finanzsachen nicht interessiere.
Ich müsste eigentlich Geld investieren.
Das ist halt die Sache.
Also ich habe letztens auf das normale Konto geguckt.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht so im Detail erzählen.
Das ist nur so grob.
Also ich habe letztens auf das normale Konto mal wieder Geld abgehoben
und da kriegst du am Geldautomat immer angezeigt, wie viel noch drauf ist.
Und also das Konto, wo ich mein Geld, also mein Monatsgehalt drauf kriege,
also nicht die Twitch-YouTube-Geschichte.
Und das war mittlerer 5-stelliger Betrag, der einfach so sinnlos drauf liegt.
Was echt fail ist, weil man darauf keine Zinsen kriegt
und das Geld eigentlich immer nur weniger wird.
Das heißt, ich muss unbedingt meine Kohle irgendwie mal anlegen.
Stonks, ja genau.
Bitconnect ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Das habe ich gesehen, das fand ich nicht so gut.
Das fand ich nicht so interessant.
Das habe ich vorhin schon mal geguckt, wo ich noch nicht hier on war.
Die Sache ist halt die, wenn du irgendwelche Typen hast, die für dich die Sachen verwalten,
dann ist halt die Frage, ob sich das lohnt, insofern, weil die wollen ja auch was verdienen drin.
Wirft YouTube denn passiv noch einen ansehnlichen Betrag ab?
Nö.
17 Euro letzten Monat.
Das Einzige, was ein bisschen was bringt, ist Amazon Reflinks.
Das ist noch ein bisschen was.
Aber aktuell muss ich sagen, gefällt es mir auf Twitch viel besser.
Erstens, weil ich hier irgendwelche Technikgeschichten machen kann,
die ich auf YouTube nie machen könnte.
Und die Subs sind auch nicht schlecht.
Also ich finde das hier auf Twitch viel angenehmer gerade.
Ich meine, ich könnte noch viel mehr Sellout machen.
Ich hätte mir für Jahre schon irgendwie einen Patreon-Account machen können.
Ich hätte mir natürlich, nicht zu vergessen, OnlyFans-Account machen können.
Was auch immer.
Man kann auf YouTube ja mittlerweile abonnieren und sonst was.
Ich könnte noch deutlich mehr Sellout machen.
Aber wozu? Warum?
Behaltet lieber eure Kohle und macht damit was Sinnvolles.
Spendet was an euer Tierheim oder sonst wie.
Damit habt ihr bestimmt mehr bewirkt,
wie den meisten Twitch-Streamern und YouTube-Leuten irgendwie was zu geben.
Das Einzige, was ich immer richtig nice finde, ist natürlich,
also ich freue mich über jeden Sub.
Ich will jetzt nicht Anti-Werbung machen, dass keiner mehr abonnieren sollte oder so.
Prime-Subs ist was, das kann man immer machen.
Prime-Subs ist ja quasi was, was verfällt, wenn man es nicht macht.
Also eigentlich ist man blöd, wenn man keine Prime-Subs vergibt.
Ich vergebe auch immer meinen Prime-Sub.
Meistens an Dance Gaming.
Weil wenn man eh Prime hat und seinen Prime nicht vergibt, ist verschenkt.
Letztendlich gibst du der Amazon indirekt Geld.
Also naja, gut, Amazon.
Also eigentlich nicht, weil es kommt von Amazon und es geht wieder an Amazon.
Aber es geht auch ein Teil an den Streamer.
Also eigentlich ist blöd, wenn man es an Amazon Prime-Sub nicht vergibt.
Ja, aber ansonsten, was ich halt nicht so genau verstehe, ist,
wenn man sich so Riesen-Streamer anguckt
und du hast dann Leute, die ihr letztes Hemd donaten.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Es gab doch diesen, ich habe vergessen, wie der heißt,
dieser eine Typ, der bei...
der dann pleite war und ins Krankenhaus musste
und die Krankenhausrechnung nicht bezahlen konnte,
weil er Twitch donatet hat.
Ich glaube, der hat bei Ninja immer donatet.
Ähm, wie ist der denn?
Top.
Wie hieß der Typ denn?
Ich glaube, das war bei Ninja, hat er donatet.
Tragic, keine Ahnung.
Was ist der Typ denn?
Tja, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, der hat bei Ninja immer donatet.
Und danach ist rausgekommen, der hat sich komplett pleite donatet
und danach hat er so eine GoFoundMe-Kampagne gestartet,
dass er seine Krankenhausrechnung bezahlen konnte.
Deswegen verstehe ich es teilweise nicht,
dass Leute, Riesen-Streamer, wo das jetzt echt nicht darum geht,
ob die jetzt diese eine Donation kriegen oder nicht,
dass ich um ihr letztes Hemd donate und es haben, das muss nicht sein.
Nein, der hieß irgendwie anders.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Wie hieß dieser Typ?
Twitch, Donations, Tragic, Hospital, wie heißt dieser Typ?
Der hier.
War das das hier?
Ja, genau.
Genau, genau, genau, den meine ich, den Typ meine ich.
Genau, dann muss er irgendwie eine GoFoundMe-Kampagne starten,
dass er seine Krankenhausrechnung bezahlen kann und so was.
Den Typ meine ich.
Der hat wie viel donatet?
300.000 Euro hat er donatet auf Twitch.
Und dann vielleicht war es eine Fake-GoFoundMe.
Aber trotzdem, also schon hat es Zeug.
Mal was anderes, schon mal was mit ULP gemacht auf dem ESP.
Ja, habe ich.
Wir haben vor Jahren mal im Stream ein bisschen ULP gebastelt.
Und wo ich per ULP Sensor gecheckt habe und aufgeweckt habe,
ist, ich habe so einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor,
der über LoRa Sachen verschickt, weil er eineinhalb Kilometer weit weg ist.
Und der checkt per ULP, ob der Sensor quasi über einen gewissen Wert ist
und erst dann wacht er auf, dass die Batterie länger hält.
Das habe ich aber nicht direkt über Assembler gemacht,
sondern mit diesen Assembler-Makros, die man verwenden kann.
Also man macht ganz normalen ESP32-Sketch
und kann das über 10 Makros auch programmieren.
Wo siehst du dich in 10 Jahren?
Alter, wie ich solche Fragen immer kann.
Das ist ja so die typische Frage.
Wenn demjenigen, der dich was fragen soll, selbst nichts einfällt.
In 10 Jahren, da sehe ich mich, dass ich 46 bin.
Ganz schön alt, oder?
Ich bin jetzt schon alt.
Die eigentliche wichtige Frage ist doch eigentlich viel mehr nicht,
wo sieht man sich in 10 Jahren oder wo sah man sich vor 10 Jahren,
sondern die eigentliche wichtige Frage ist doch,
ist man halbwegs zufrieden mit dem, wo man sich heute sieht?
Was macht eigentlich der Frazier und der Kaboom?
Denen geht es beiden gut, der Friseur streamt.
Mal gucken, ob der gerade wieder streamt.
Der Friseur streamt jetzt seit ein paar Wochen wieder halbwegs regelmäßig.
Irgendwelche Weep-Games.
Dem Kaboom geht es auch gut, aber der hat mit YouTube nichts mehr am Hut.
Was möchte eigentlich Twitch hier oben?
Ich bin doch gar nicht eingeloggt.
Prime Loot, exzellent.
Die wichtigste Frage ist, gibt es in 10 Jahren neue Emotes?
Das ist tatsächlich eine wichtige Frage.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es immer noch fest vor, endlich mal Emotes zu machen,
aber ihr kennt mich, wie schwer ich mich immer überwinden kann,
Sachen zu machen.
Fiverr, ich gehe auf Fiverr und kaufe mir Emotes.
Ich lasse mir einfach ein paar inneren Twitch-Emotes malen.
Komm mal, 444, da kannst du nichts falsch machen.
837.
Hat die Emotes gefallen mir nicht.
300 Emotes am...
What the fuck?
Hab ich das gerade im Hintergrund husten gehört?
What the fuck, was ist hier los?
Okay, das sind mehrere Leute, die das machen.
Sonst kriegst du das dann nicht hin.
Das sind die passenden Emotes.
Also wenn das die Barra sich aussuchen könnte,
was wir für Emotes machen,
dann sind das wahrscheinlich die hier.
Was ist das in der Richtung?
Schwier zu sagen.
Das Problem, was für mich schwierig ist,
ich habe zwar ein paar Emote-Ideen,
aber ich kann das denen nicht so gut beschreiben,
dass was rauskommt, was mir gefällt.
Ich bin da recht wählerisch,
also bei dem, was mir gefällt, als Ergebnis.
Und deswegen ist das schwierig.
Ich kann dem nicht sagen, ich will so und so haben,
und bei den ersten zwei Tries kommt dann was raus,
was mir gefällt.
Also es ist eher so, dass dann...
Ich hab so eine grobe Idee, der bastelt was,
und ich kann ihm was sagen,
nee, lieber so und so, und dann so und so,
und dann so und so.
Ich brauch wahrscheinlich 10 Iterations pro Emote,
bis mir das gefällt.
Wenn überhaupt.
Woop, Kobold.
Woop, Heizung.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Heizung sind.
Heute nicht, na, heute nicht.
Ich mein, so Emotes kriege ich auch noch gebacken.
Gibt es neue Emotes?
Ja, es wird mal Zeit, dass es neue Emotes gibt.
Wie gesagt, ich hab jede Menge gute Emote-Ideen
auch schon aufgeschrieben.
Ich hab ne riesig lange Liste, bestimmt 50 verschiedene
Emote-Ideen auch.
Wie viel freie Slots hast du?
Ich glaub, 20 oder so.
Warte mal, ich guck mal nach,
wie viel freie Slots ich hab.
Wie viele Emotes hab ich denn aktuell drinne?
Vier, okay.
Also die Emotes, die ich drinne hab,
also bis auf Woop S und Woop,
also Woop Old ist ja mehr oder weniger auch nur geklaut
und ein paar Pixel verändert.
Also Woop S und Woop Old kommen auf jeden Fall wieder rein.
Den anderen Kram brauchen wir nicht.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie viel Emote-Slots ich frei hab.
Wartet mal, ich guck mal.
Äh, Moment.
So, wenn ich jetzt rausfinde, wo man das sieht.
Äh, Partner.
Konto, ach du Scheiße, wo sieht man das überhaupt?
Creator, ne, Einstellung.
Community.
Im Dashboard bin ich schon.
Followerliste, Inhalt.
Ne, ich muss bestimmt irgendwie in die Settings oder so.
Ich find das übelst unübersichtlich bei
Kontoeinstellung vielleicht.
Ich find das übelst unübersichtlich,
hier auf Twitch was zu finden.
Ja, wo könnte das sein?
Einstellung, Kanal, Stream, Partner.
Das klingt gut.
Partner.
Cheer Emote.
Emote.
Ah ja, okay, okay, okay.
Ja, 20, 20 hab ich.
Excellent.
Also kann ich noch 16 Emotes reinmachen.
Ach so, plus.
Ne.
Moment, die, es gibt ja da noch, es gibt ja da noch, ähm,
Sub-Only, ähm, Tier 2 und 3 Emotes irgendwie.
Ja.
Kommt auch noch dabei.
Ja, ne.
Wird mal Zeit.
Wird, wird echt mal Zeit.
Ich glaub, ich such mir heute irgendeinen Fiverr-Account raus.
Ich werd jetzt gleich was zu Mittagessen machen.
Und dann setz ich mich mal hin und geb einfach mal Twitch,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt so,
diesen 0815-Weep-Emote-Style ein und such mir mal irgendwas raus,
was mir gefällt.
Wann eigentlich mal CACW es ist Service?
Ja, gibt's doch laufend.
CACW es ist Service.
Ne, das war ja mal eine Idee des, äh, was ich mir überlegt hab,
was man in irgendeinem Stream machen könnte,
dass wir mal nen Web-Service programmieren.
Ich hab ihn halt mal bescheuerterweise CACW es ist Service gelernt.
Und von Anfang an wird das für den Kram programmieren,
dass wir ordentlich, ähm,
dass wir das Ganze auf GitHub pushen,
dass wir dort irgendeine Pipeline zum automatisch Bilden einrichten
und dass wir uns irgendwas suchen, wo wir das Ganze kostenlos hosten können.
Alles quasi in einem Stream.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, mal so zum angucken,
was man da so kostenlos mittlerweile alles bekommt.
CACW, CAS ist das dann, CAS.
CACW es ist Service.
Ja, mach's gut, C-Baro.
Leute, ich bin übrigens auch gleich weg.
Ich guck mir das, ich guck mir das, what the fuck.
Genau, die passenden Emotes für mich.
Exzellent, hallo.
Warum sind das alles nur cute, oh, Katzen-Emotes,
das ist doch schon mal gut.
Warum, warum sind das alles so cute Emotes?
Deswegen finde ich die Dance-Gaming-Emotes cool,
weil die haben einen eigenen Style.
Guck mal hier.
Die haben, die haben irgendwie einen eigenen Style.
Gut, das sind jetzt die ganzen Halloween-Emotes,
das sind nicht die normalen Emotes.
Ja, man muss mal unbedingt,
der hat einfach alle Emotes zu Halloween ausgetauscht,
aber der kann das auch machen,
weil der hat eine eigene Designerin, die nur für zwei Leute nichts anderes macht,
als für zwei Leute Emotes zu designen.
Klar kann ich sagen, wie meine Emotes aussehen sollen,
aber erstens erkennt man den Style der Leute hier schon ganz gut
und ich bin da künstlerisch nicht so big brain,
dass ich ihm das genau sagen könnte.
Ich könnte ihm sagen, okay, ich habe so und so ungefähr eine Vorstellung,
aber ich weiß jetzt schon, dass mir das erste,
was der aufgrund dieser Beschreibung macht, nicht gefallen wird.
Und dann sind sie wahrscheinlich gleich pissed,
wenn ich sage, okay, das müssen wir noch mal machen,
noch mal machen, noch mal machen.
Gut, solange ich es bezahle, ist es denen alles egal.
Das sind ja nur Cute-Emotes.
Es ist unglaublich, wie viele Emotes es gibt auf Fiverr, oder?
Ich meine, warum sind das alles Cute-Emotes?
Wisst ihr, ich sage nicht, dass die Emotes schlecht sind.
Ganz im Gegenteil, die sehen zum größten Teil richtig cool aus.
Aber man muss halt sagen, das ist so, diese Cute-Emote,
also MoonMoon war der erste Channel, der mir so richtig aufgefallen ist,
diese Art von damals bei Overwatch,
der so diese gezeichneten teilweise ein bisschen Cute-Emotes hatte.
Die waren nicht wirklich cute, aber es war so in die Richtung gegangen.
Es war bei MoonMoon zum ersten Mal, wo ich das gesehen habe.
Und in den letzten zwei Jahren gibt es quasi nur noch Cute-Emotes.
Und was mir daran halt nicht gefällt ist, dass das halt,
guck mal, es ist klar, du erkennst, dass es unterschiedliche Emotes sind,
aber wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt, hier dazwischen, hier dazwischen,
oder hier dazwischen, da dazwischen,
das ist einfach so alles mehr oder weniger ähnlich.
Ja, ich weiß, ich muss mir das gleich mal angucken.
Ich werde jetzt was zum Mittagessen machen,
dann gucke ich mir mal Emotes-Leute an.
Das ist richtig, Michael 50 Billion.
Du darfst in den Emote einen Emote aussuchen.
Ich habe das nicht vergessen.
Ich weiß zwar nicht mehr, für was.
Ach, weil ich dich mal geflamed habe.
Ich glaube, ich kann mich daran erinnern.
Ja, kannst du mal...
SelfmadeEyes, fünf Monate, Dankeschön.
Huge Subscription.
Ich würde durchscrollen,
als ich noch was vergessen habe, hier zu erwähnen.
Thomascool110, weiß nicht, ob ich schon erwähnt habe,
aber Dankeschön für sechs Monate Subs.
Moment.
Ach, ich kann mich wieder dran erinnern.
So Leute, ich gehe jetzt Mittagessen machen
und danach gucke ich mir mal an,
was es für Pfeifer-Emote-Leute gibt,
wo ich denke, dass die mir gute Emotes machen können.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob heute Mittag noch mal.
Aber ich hatte gestern noch keine, gestern Freitag
hatte ich keine Zeit, großartig zu streamen.
Ich habe aber verhältnismäßig viel gestreamt in letzter Zeit.
Ihr müsst ja mal dazugeben hier.
Für meine Verhältnisse war ich ziemlich oft on.
Guck mal hier.
Viel, aber nicht genug.
Na ja, aber guck mal, ich meine,
das ist für meine Verhältnisse 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Sechs Streams in sieben Tagen.
Was ist denn da los?
Wobei, ne, das kann nicht sein.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ja, doch.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Mal gucken, ob der Friseur online ist.
Da kann man nicht den Frasier hosten.
Ne, ist er nicht.
Alles klar.
Wir sehen uns, machts gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
See you.
Bis dann.